so I got some uranium
so this is the point like I called the
government at the time I was like
hypothetic
if I wanted to work
welcome back to this episode of trash
taste today we have a very special guest
Nigel from Nile red Hello uh you might
have know his voice if you don't know
his face yes he give us a little a taste
of what one might say just so can you
tell us I'm sorry I don't have it hello
what okay what is it you have to start
with what I have here yeah yeah please
please do the intro
okay fine what I have here is a Rubik's
Cube yes yes okay thank you so I think
you're on the tier list of YouTubers
that if they were in prison would be
terrifying uh you're up there with lock
picking lawyer and you and then I don't
know who else is there and Michael right
in my head in my head I imagine like
YouTubers you wouldn't want to be or
would want to be in a prison cell with
because that's just strictly because of
what they do yeah because of what you do
yeah I feel like I could be pleasant
impressive no you'd be pleasant but I
would be terrified of what you're
getting up to yeah
what I have here today is I would
definitely
be do like you don't need I know those
you see those prison documentaries and
there's like they show like the guys
just doing some weird stuff yeah so I'd
definitely be one of those yeah yeah I'd
be scared of having to sell with me I
liked it like little pieces from my
meals yeah I I'd be I'd come back to
myself you'd be like do you smell
almonds and I'm like yeah no why is that
good yeah yeah I would do that yeah yeah
what I have here is a Knife
by the way I think the mic needs to be
close to your mouth I was talking more
about cyanide oh yeah sorry we forgot to
mention before the podcast yeah you kind
of like be really close to the mic I
just speak really loud okay yeah that
works too that works that works as well
so yeah if you don't know Nigel Nigel
does chemistry videos on YouTube and
makes quite bizarre things I'd say yeah
you've definitely seen them on like
YouTube what's some of the greatest hits
yeah yeah when when someone recognizes
you what is the video that they always
bring up to be like oh you're that guy
from X video I think it depends real
like some of the videos are normal right
yeah like I just made
I made things like just materials like I
made Arrow gel yeah like a super
conductor that was awesome those are
just like I'd say like oh yeah perfect
but I see airgel every day of the week
superconductors yeah you made uh gloves
out of grape or hot sauce yeah so that's
probably like for it's still just
chemistry so it's like a bit further
away from normal like the transition is
a bit odd but I think the thing that
people call me out on that I'm always
like is like is the the stuff I did with
pee
ha
well when you try to drink your own pee
there was a Okay no Okay okay there was
a bunch I've made probably
a couple full-length videos involving P
where I involved my own p and then
it's worse yeah yeah but and for one of
the long ones I did actually it wasn't
my pee I was in in in first p in part of
the we've actually talked to this on
like on my podcast before right with the
um
I did one on Diabetes yeah this is like
early in the channel and a friend was
diabetic or is diabetic yeah but the
early way that they detected it was by
tasting it and to see if it's sweet what
so he yeah because there could be sugar
in it and so like when I first thought
of the video I'm like yeah I'll taste it
but I chickened out I couldn't do it you
didn't touch your friends pee no okay I
I couldn't do it that would have been a
pretty epic moment I don't know why like
I would definitely remember you for that
if you did that I was waiting for like
the I was waiting for the information to
match up there where you're telling that
story so so you're like yeah so I did a
video with Pete uh so how that started
it's my friend was diabetic
um
why I decided to do that video I thought
it was interesting like just the whole
way that like um that's how it started
people didn't know what diabetes was
yeah yeah and then it was like some of
the early doctors I guess I mean they I
think they tasted people's blood they
just like it's I mean they they they did
you had to do what you had to do right
must have been like the biggest
casualties back in the day from just
eating this [ __ ] and just drinking
people's hepatitis ridden blood I think
that yeah they definitely like the
peanut cup and he's just you sit
not what I was expecting like I think
diabetes like the full name diabetes
mellitus just I forget what diabetes
means but it means melodis means sweet
right so it comes after like the taste
so but then since then obviously the
goal was to to get a method that didn't
involve tasting me uh so then there was
a chemical method yeah they found out
how to test things yeah test for sugar
with chemistry okay and then that was
not very useful so then they started
using like uh digital products
we know a guy we know a guy I just
thought it was great
so I wanted to do a video on it yeah but
the one that I use my own pee was I
wanted to make there was a sweetener
that you can make from urea right right
in your piece yeah I collected a bunch
of my own pee I boiled it off in my
backyard
I'm assuming you don't use this like
saucepan anymore sorry did you use this
pen anymore oh I know it's probably long
gone okay I was gonna say yeah sell it
for some Goodwill someone else will have
a use for it I think the pee smell never
came out of it so I just
I used for that video just there's just
this musty piece there's there's nothing
more unpleasant sounding than boiling
pink you know
it's bad at the beginning right it was
like a hot summer day and remember I sat
there just I think I was like reading a
book called The Bee was just boiling
so you see this in your backyard but you
you know it's back here oh my god um you
were the neighbor's kids
yeah no we did some stuff the neighbor I
don't think I could have the channel if
my neighbors weren't more tolerant right
wow we did a lot of stuff where they
just I remember one day I was trying to
distill Mercury I was doing it in my
driveway in your driveway yeah I had
like a full like I think I was I was
trying to be careful so I had like a
respirator on I had like a full coat and
everything oh my God and The Neighbor
comes over yeah and they're like what
are you doing and it's just like boiling
metal and I'm like oh I'm distilling
Mercury he's like cool
that's cool I'm like man I would not be
this cool elimination yeah if my
neighbor was distilling Mercury I think
I'd be like hey government can you do
something about this guy he's [ __ ] he
has to be on a watch list he's got
uranium in the back and he's making
uranium things I'm kind of scared my
neighbors and my parents in general were
just they just I think Canada too just
like the government also doesn't seem to
care I mean maybe saying this
don't let them know what so so okay so
you're making all this chemistry stuff
and you're doing it for YouTube it's all
for YouTube right like yeah I mean like
how would you describe your content to
someone like maybe some people in the
audience how would you describe someone
your content to people who don't know
what you do I think maybe I should say
how it started yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
sure no I'm saying like just for it to
make sense right
just random projects so as a kid I used
to build a lot of things right so I I
made like bike jumps and just I tried to
build a bunch of random stuff and then
somebody went into fireworks and
firecrackers
this is that's a big jump from like tiny
little jumps to explosive [ __ ] so
because in Canada you can't buy
firecrackers oh really well well are
they just like it's more concerning that
you were playing with them yeah so like
whenever you get them could you buy
cracks as well sorry because you buy
black jumps as well they start being as
uh yeah what age are we talking about
now when you've gone to file shockingly
young I'd say look I would never let a
kid do that like probably
this is like the one story I have with
my neighbor too like we were trying to
make smoke I was trying to make smoke
bombs with my brother and we found the
recipe right in a book because you had
to go to the library to find these
recipes this is insane wait how old were
you I think I was nine or ten oh my God
I thought it was just like smoke bombs
so this is like your teenage years no no
no no I was like so we made it we've
like basically in the book it says even
heating don't overheat it my brother and
I were like oh we can get away with a
blow torch and we overheated it so it
went off in the garage and Smoke's
pouring everywhere and then put it out
there's like ash all over my dad's stuff
I'm freaked out and shot water all over
it's All Electronics but the neighbors
like do we need like the fire department
it's a there's just smoke pouring and
we're like no it's okay we got this and
she's like okay so you were doing that
stuff at nine times Legos yeah we were
doing I this is insane yeah this is
insanity I think and I gotta I remember
all the members are coming back so like
one thing we did was you know like
little caps you put my cap guns yeah
Australia
where do you think I'm from oh Britain
here
I'm not from a person
with cap guns is that we do have those
we have those paper Caps or the little
plastic ones you put in a fake gun and
oh oh just go back I thought you meant
the ones that they use in like the race
guns those are starter Pistons those are
much louder Oh okay little kid toys
right yeah the ones that make the sound
but nothing comes out all right yeah
yeah okay yeah I think I know those yeah
I think we have those in the UK I don't
know I thought some people I don't know
maybe I don't know but my I think I was
like 10 or 11. my friend and I would we
found that you could take the paper caps
you could cut them all up and I'd pack
them in like really tightly and you can
put them in a paintball gun and then
shoot it and explode where did you get a
paintball gun from oh I got it at the
store my parents let me buy all this
what the [ __ ] your parents are so lucky
that you still have all your limbs how
are you not maimed because my dad I mean
I think the big thing is my dad the
reason we did it because my dad liked
firecrackers and he liked all this stuff
too and I think the reason that we
didn't get hurt was because our first
experience was he taught us everything
so he would be like right the thing like
you'd be like never light a firecracker
and throw it because as a kid he's like
I don't think his friends ever lost
their fingers but he's like we he was we
had some close calls and I think a
friend did lose like a piece of things
so he's like no you don't do that you
light and run yeah so like he taught us
a lot of that stuff and we like BB guns
at like 10 but he's like always wear
safety glasses like we learned all our
guns he's a gun where's some glasses he
was always there with us light and run
is that the official safety regulation
just slide and run just like run it just
if you light it you're not holding it
okay so sir okay so you're doing that
and then in the library there was yeah I
never even like it this is a huge
tangent yeah no it's just there's no
internet at the time so but in the
library there was a book that taught you
how to make smoke bombs well Loosely
they just kind of said like smoke bombs
are made using this
oh and you just extrapolate it you're
like oh well I can get that getting
actually not remember getting potassium
nitrate which is also called salt as you
do we couldn't buy it we couldn't buy it
but I don't even know what you buy now
well I know you just buy it online now
like eBay and stuff but my dad was like
oh your grandfather has some left I
don't know where he got it from me
you realize that everything you've said
so far is insane like this is all every
single beat of the story is insane this
story has got progressively more insane
the more you've said I don't know I
don't know why he had it so this really
old like just it was just in our garage
do you want to make a smoke bomb and
then you get this book and you go to
your dad and you're like Hey Dad I want
to make the smoke bomb yeah
instead of you instead of your dad being
like no Sean come on that's silly he's
like oh yeah I'll I'll get some
potassium potassium potassium nitrate
potassium nitrate of course yeah
naturally we did have a successful smoke
bomb after the first failed one
what happened what was the difference
between the failed one and the
successful well we overheated the first
one it went off while we're making it so
it's like it just spilled the house with
like the whole garage was your dad
watching you the first time you're
making the smoke no he was watching TV
so and then and then you [ __ ] it up so
badly he was like all right when you're
gonna do it again let me watch no I
think my brother and I just just said
okay we shouldn't have used the blood
targets
did your dad never like question me like
why is the garage smoking my dad is
inexplicably tolerant to like I think
it's because as a kid he my dad did some
crazy stuff as a kid yeah like the BB
guns he taught us how to shoot as a kid
he was like we had BB gun wars with no
safety glasses because you just shoot
each other and he goes I remember many
days I'd come home and you have to pick
BB's out with tweezers oh my God I was
like if they hit your eyes like I don't
know I guess he went blind we never
thought about it and I was like what
about your mum this whole time is she
just like for [ __ ] sake my mom got mad
at us for like everything I remember
there was one time my mom got mad okay
because only one this is this is gonna
sound even like it this is great
at this point so just like these
memories coming back I talked to my
brother about this recently so we were
like fascinated by fire okay we were
like we were like what age is this
I think about the same age oh my nine
like nine ten ten oh my God so 9 10
Fascinate with fire okay we like to do
like the idea I remember days I'd come
home but I would just go in my garage I
just pour like some paint thinner into a
can and just light it on fire just
because I was like I just like burning
stuff
so that's how people become awesomeness
so
we like oh my God okay okay okay so we
would like to do is like soak a rag in
like some paint thinner or something you
just made a mulch off no no no no no we
wrap it around like a stick and we'd
like to light it on fire and just like
swing it around as we were like 10. so
you made like the Torches yeah yeah and
so like what my this is like the extra
level I said my brother I remember
exactly what he did I found out a way to
like I remember exactly what he did he
like packed the rag but he shot like
WD-40 on it or something and what he my
older brother did was he would like
I remember exactly he made like it would
be fiery but he was in a tube and he'd
like blow on it like smoke would come
out and he would use it to like we'd
wasp an ass he'd use it to turn like oh
my God I don't remember if it ever
worked my mom my brother would do that
and then I would be like swinging around
like this fiery stick and we thought she
wasn't home and when she came home
because we'd light it in the front and
run to the bathroom
running through the backyard like giant
flaming sticks and my mom was like yeah
that's so that that's not your household
is just like Ed and Eddie like IRL just
like Phineas and Ferb but like it was
way more dangerous literally that scene
from Community with a [ __ ] childish
gambling yeah
everything's on fire
okay he didn't I think the big thing too
is like Iris like I respected my parents
yeah so when my mom caught us and told
us don't do that I think I did we did
stop like we stopped I'd like to think
so we just you you would be an
interesting uh study I think like is it
is it not your own nature let's find out
what makes a kid can become obsessed
with fire is it genetics or is it I
think everyone is obsessed with fire to
a point I mean you know it's [ __ ]
it's hypnotizing you know yeah
especially setting things on fire
I get you I get you okay with him he is
an awesomest I had a bad experience
though which I then didn't light
anything on fire for two years yeah I do
tell it's crazy uh so the big change for
me was when I hit 12 where you could buy
a lighter right all right what they just
wouldn't sell lighters if you're less
than younger than 12. why are they
selling lettuce to 12 year olds
what a reason would a 12 everyone need a
lighter for I don't even know like your
dad's cigarettes I like I like how you
know this presumably you went to the
store they would never let you buy it
and then did you go before 12. yeah
there you go you're too young and for
some reason
every birthday
yeah this is the yeah no but there's
just an arbitrary age okay
okay the the law before you can buy
light is is I believe 16.
yeah so I don't know why I thought 12 in
my head okay I don't think I've ever
bought a lighter
I didn't I didn't buy a ladder until I
was like in my 20s I've just bought
those kitchen lighters you know the ones
the long ones oh oh yeah yeah I bought
my first blowtorch when I was 12. oh my
[ __ ] okay okay all right
okay
so it's just like a choose your
adventure I gotta navigate which tangent
I want to go down here that one's
actually more the blowchart one's more
related to chemistry but all right okay
let's save the blowtorch then after okay
why did you become scared of five two
years oh so what happened was my friend
the one who I built like you know the
firecracker explodey paintball gun thing
yeah and as you do all a lot of this
stuff was with my friend right
um growing up and what happened was
foreign
in Montreal I don't know if it happens
elsewhere it was around like sometime in
the summer yeah there would be
like this big pollination thing and
there'd be everything we covered in
white fluff but we found out that if you
light it on fire the fire just like
travels as like a wave down it right
it's a massive fire hazard I don't know
how it even like yeah it's just it's
sitting around all the time okay so it
was really fun we'd bike around if you
found somebody light it on fire
but you'd always be careful and so like
oh yeah yeah okay I believe you I told
my friend light and run right now I told
my friend like if you're gonna light it
make sure that you see the end of it
like it's not gonna just spread out yeah
and he's like yeah yeah I got you but
when he lit one he he lit it and then he
comes to me goes
he's just freaking out because he just
started like traveling yeah so you could
have like a patch this bag you light it
just like yeah it's gone but it expanded
here but then he really was connected to
two things here and he just went and
just like it just Chain Reaction you try
to stomp it out before you know it it's
covering like you know an area that you
can it's like huge and then it goes into
leaves and like sticks and just like you
start having fire like this High what
did it almost started a Bushfire but
yeah did it get put out well so what
happens probably like it was like a long
offense it was probably like from that
wall like twice the length there there
was like foot long fire like flames and
like maybe like half the depth of this
room to the point where you're like you
cannot stomp this out you're the fire is
just there did it go out eventually so
multiple people came by it's really
weird to think about like the cars
pulled up and they're like oh no that's
like a real fire like should we call the
fire department they're asking 12 year
olds oh no we were 11. would it be like
should we call the fire department and
we're like no no we're putting it out
they're like okay and they just left
what they just left and then this old
lady came by and we're like we asked
like can we have some water yeah yeah I
think we've asked another guy I don't
live out here and just left but like the
lady's like okay and she just walked so
slowly and eventually we got water from
her by the time we came back the fire
was like yeah it was so long so you're
very lucky that it kind of dissipated
yeah but we panicked but what the scary
part was behind it was like a
chain-linked fence holding all these
leaves but behind it was like multiple
yards like backyards of people that were
filled with old leaves and like thick
amounts oh my God people have wood decks
we're like it might have just burned
people's houses yeah yeah and so we kind
of just panicked and my friend was like
I'm never lighting a fire again and he
just threw his lighter into like the
forest and then it just set a place
we vowed to like never light a fire
again we didn't sleep properly for like
like a week well yeah because you guys
were one step away from being Arsenal so
so you very quickly got over your trauma
then it took two years and you're back
at it I never really like
I kind of just stopped lighting things
on fire like I mean like for that period
I just didn't I just didn't like fire
make it sound like it's something to be
like applauded like congratulations
arson is anonymous right now so so I've
been uh two years Fire free haven't let
anything on fire so I saw a match the
other day what was the moment where one
day your brain was just like I'm in a
lot of fun I mean like so to to clarify
it's more like when people would be like
oh like I go to I was still pretty young
people like oh we're going to a family
friend's place they have a fire in the
backyard right I can't be like yeah I'm
not like I might not even go out and see
the fire like I was kind of just like I
brought back like a very negative
feeling yeah I don't even want to be the
guilt that I didn't even want to own a
lighter because I not because I couldn't
help myself
just like literally holding it like
brought up so much like panic because I
I we literally thought we were gonna go
to like like kid jail yeah jail like
juvie or something yeah like we actually
thought because at the time both my
friend and I wanted to go to med school
we're like our lives would be to be over
yeah yeah yeah oh I want to be in bed I
was like our lives would be over so
it'll get represented so much negativity
I just didn't even want to own matches
yeah yeah
um and then obviously like two years
later you're kind of like okay and kind
of there are situations where you like
you might be like you're at like I'm at
my parents house my mom's like here's
the lighter can you light the birthday
cake I'm not gonna be like no so it's
like just eventually I just it I got
over it yeah I don't really no just I
just stopped I mean it's also a kid
phase of just lighting things oh yeah of
course cools yeah it's like she hands
you the lights and you're staring yeah
it's like those horror movies where like
the whole room just like
do you have any other Antics from your
childhood involving very dangerous
things you shouldn't have been doing
a lot of the my experiences are actually
kind of similar to the fire thing like I
had a couple negative experiences that
just made me stop yeah
um the firecrackers was like we kept I
built I made a firecracker with my
friend and we were super proud of wait
how did you make a fight you opened up
like all individual caps and like packed
them into a little taper roll we made
those are really dangerous because
they're pressure sensitive so if you
screw up it'll just blow up
this is insane but we started getting
because you can't buy firecrackers in
Canada but you can buy the ones that
shoot up in the air and explode and I
realize you could just unpeel them and
take them apart but like we try to blow
you realize that no one should realize
that I think that's actually just a
crime so is it actually probably I don't
know but I I I I I've never gone anymore
I've never had a firework in film I
should open this up yeah let's see
what's going on yeah no I wanted the
firecracker in it oh my but then I
started realizing like we were they were
big enough that like I think if you held
them they would literally blow your hand
off yeah well I have some videos I can
show you a test like we bought a chicken
cutlet from the from the store and we we
wrapped it yeah and I put it on like a
stand next to the fence I want to
explode it it just sprayed like paste on
the fence and I was like yeah it's not a
perfect record we shouldn't be holding
it but like your hand would be gone yeah
like you would have even if it doesn't
blow your fingers off you probably have
like chunks of your fingers missing and
I remember just for some reason I was
like I just got scared and I was like
yeah that's cool
and then I just stopped working with
explosives like nothing actually
happened actually that's not true but so
come on so this you are the scariest I
mean this is why you're the one I do not
want to be in a prison so what we've
this is actually now that I'm thinking
it's like therapy like yeah this is okay
this is this is great this is great so
what happened was there are people
whether like this monetizes it my dad
vaguely told us about about this he's
like if you put two firecrackers in a
tube and with open ends and you link it
up properly you can launch one
firecracker out that's lit and you can
have it explode in the air okay so why
did he tell you this he said he did as a
kid and it was like your dad is insane
so we did that a bunch yeah right and it
worked but then my dad also alluded to
the fact that he's like you could put a
BB in the tube and it's like a god
so you made a gun no but so I guess you
better go you made a projector you made
an explosive that shoots a projectile
wait I'm not gonna say it outright in a
cylinder this was let's this is many
years ago for legal reasons as many
years ago so what happened was we did
that we put one BB in it worked really
well yeah but then I was like if you put
a lot of BBS in and you've made
but the problem is like my dad also see
I think the safety thing he's like never
sealed a tube because like if anything
happens it'll actually just like she
trapped and a lot like so it'll be a
grenade yeah so he's like so we never
sealed it but I put all these BBS in the
front
and when I lit the back of it I put too
many BBS so it kind of like sealed the
end and shot all of like the firecracker
like debris and stuff backwards yeah but
my hand was in the way oh [ __ ] so I
remember it went off and then my hand
just went numb yeah and I thought I
thought I like lost my hand but I just I
just kidding Pat I was you know kid
panic but I looked at it I remember I
just had like it just it was like
basically shotgun blasted with like
little like pieces I don't think it's
not concrete but it's like a solid thing
on each end that they make the
firecrackers out of yeah so and I just
had like a hundreds of little blood
blisters on my hand
oh my God I can't believe I'm saying
this but you like but that's what's
that's what put the fear of explosives
in your head because I was like
a highly fear of explosives and I've
never had my hand blown off I can't
believe I'm saying this you make Michael
Reeves look well adjusted
it's crazy
the fact that you still have all your
fingers is like America okay so so
you're you're in school at this point
right so you start high school or middle
school
in Canada yeah we don't have Middle
School in the UK yeah we have certain
schools middle schools around Canada but
in Quebec we have uh just a high school
then we have something called sejap
which is between high school and
University yeah we have something like
that okay we have University oh okay so
so you go into high school and then
presumably you're still doing this stuff
or so yeah escalated grade seven I
remember was when I bought the blowtorch
were you okay I I have to ask you and
this is relevant to my YouTube were the
other kids scared of you
did they know what you were doing they
shouldn't tell people I brought the
blood George to school
and I kept it in my locker and I would
show it to people oh my God you were the
one quiet kid I generally if you if I if
you were a kid in my school and you'd a
blowtorch I'd be like everyone's stood
the [ __ ] away from me I actually burnt
my locker a few times at that time like
my dad oh my God okay okay so you so you
buy them these are memories that I
forgot about you buy the blowtor why is
it such a momentous occasion for you why
is it so special the reason it's special
is because I I don't remember exactly
why I bought the blowtorch yeah but I
think the reason why I bought it
was it was actually I used it to do my
first chemistry experiment okay what was
that what was the experience I wanted to
turn I saw on YouTube a method to take
pennies and make them different colors
oh you make them like silver or gold
right right and I was just I thought
that was a change YouTube sent me down
this rabbit hole Yeah so I wanted to
just make colored pennies yeah and flex
on the other kids right
okay I get that sentiment but
when they think oh I want different
colored pennies they just like paint
no but it looks it looks like the penny
is just a golden okay
I could understand why if if this
sounded easy to do a kid would do this
to me that was like magic because I was
like this is just this doesn't make any
sense I mean I'll give you like Street
creds in school yeah if you were able to
do that and even for me I thought it was
just like magical like paint makes sense
but to like turn it a diff like turn
just have a pen Alchemy yeah but it
looks like a nickel that's what I
thought right so I was like that's just
weird okay so what happened
um long story short actually I failed
what was the experiment what do you have
to do just you just need like some drain
cleaner right and some like zinc metal
where did you get zinc metal so again I
learned it on the internet you can like
cut open batteries
you get the battery shells and then you
get the drain cleaner the problem is at
the time I use just Drano it's like
mixed with like aluminum and a bunch of
other stuff yeah I mean I tried it it
just didn't work right and I think I
tried like twice and when it failed I
kind of gave up but it was like the
first time I actually did like isn't
cutting a battery scary
okay okay so you got very lucky you do
this and it didn't work all right then
what what's the next step I just gave up
I guess you didn't do any more chemistry
during high school but no I I'm trying
to think and then after that I got very
I I started getting back into fireworks
the fire came back no and I thought it's
a lot easier I wanted to make flash
powder what's flash powder
um it's basically what's used in
firecrackers oh is it just stuff that
lights on fire it does light on fire but
you have enough of it it just detonates
oh and I just thought it was cool is it
literally just an explosive chemicals
yeah yeah okay
so where where so yeah you failed with
the pennies you presumably go back to
normal school life what gets you back
into this your brain you're bringing up
all this I haven't even ever talked to
this I forgot about this the
I really wanted to make flash powder and
yeah to make it there's so I think it's
potassium perchlorate
and aluminum powder okay so like to make
the aluminum powder at the time you
couldn't just buy it so I bought like a
the way that there's so many ways people
talked about it but it's like aluminum
foil you shred it yeah and you put it
like a rock tumbler
so it was like the beginning of like
trying to do these projects for
chemistry and the potassium perchlorate
you buy like salt replacement at the
store and then you can do electrolysis
on it I think that's what you do I don't
know okay so as how old are you you did
this
15. and did you actually do electrolysis
when you're 15.
I so I don't I got sidetracked so I
don't think I ever made uh the flashback
the hard part I made the perchlorate but
I never made the aluminum because it was
too annoying to get the powder right so
I kind of quit I remember when they were
like when I was 16 and they were trying
to explain electrolysis to me and I was
like I don't know so this is like the
big thing about which I think going back
to what you asked about like the channel
and not really what started I did ask
about but like the mentality of it was I
didn't I never cared what electrolysis
was or how it worked it's this is how I
get what I want yeah right like it was
just a tool it's kind of like if you
have a nail and you need it to be like
hammered into something I don't care
what a hammer really is but if it works
that's what I'll use and like that's
kind of what I still do with chemistry
now right
um like I'm
I I viewed the like um I'm much more
interested in like what it can do for me
than like the actual process itself
right right yeah so you just want the
final products you just it's not that
yeah like I'm not in innately like super
deeply fascinated but it's not about the
journey it's about the destination no it
is it is kind of both I'm trying to like
explain this because when you go into
chemistry there's people who are like
very fascinated Yeah by like they'll be
like oh like the electrons move like
this like that's so fascinating and I'm
kind of like it is cool but I
to me it's only cool because they move
like that and then this is the result
right so you end up learning a lot
purely out of practical yeah
implementation yeah techniques that's
interesting this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn how do you think big tech
companies like Twitter make all their
money by mining salt Elon Musk yes but
no it's by tracking your searches your
video history and everything you click
on and then selling your personal data
no way expressvpn helps you anonymize
much your online presence by hiding your
IP address a unique identifier that
every device has that allows big tech
companies to match your activity back to
you that's why we use expressvpn here at
trash test on all of our devices to make
it much more difficult for them to
exploit our data for their own profits
and the best part is how easy the
expressvpn app is to use all you have to
do is just tap one button on your phone
or computer and Bam that's all you need
to do if you don't like big Tech
tracking you and selling your personal
data for profit it's time to fight back
visit expressvpn.com trash taste right
now to get three months of expressvpn
for free that's expressvpn.com trash
taste expressvpn.com trash taste back to
the episode unbelievable I always
wondered right uh not not to get
sidetracked we can go back into the
stream
um this is entire thing yeah
I've been like I always wondered if
because I I don't think any of us
understand the world of chemistry yeah
and I think when you're watching it it's
hard to gauge
I'm like am I watching someone who is
extremely knowledgeable and an expert at
what they're doing or am I watching a
guy who is just winging it and also just
seems really good like I don't like is
this a call ahead no I'm asking I'm
asking like like if I would have like I
on the level of like chemistry
professionals where where do you where
would you place like where would you sit
like
because like I I don't know like because
I I it's completely out of my depth and
I'm like insane to us it's so absurd to
me when I'm like this dude could tell me
he is like one of the most knowledgeable
chemistry people of all time and I'd be
like yeah I believe
I should totally make that claim no no
no so what's kind of interesting is I
remember
I mean to Jump Ahead like I started
doing all the chem stuff after I
finished a biochem degree and I was a
lab tech then it ended up being uh a
chemistry Master student okay
and that's when I started I started
pushing the envelope of like things that
I felt were quote unquote like safe okay
I say like it's like I felt safe doing
them yeah but like I started just I
guess like being having more confidence
in myself but I would ask my lab mates
for help being like Oh what do you know
about this chemical yeah and it's when I
start to realize that like
most people don't know like a broad
range of chemistry right they're very
like specialized the moment you get into
grad school you start doing like
projects that are in a certain realm but
when you ask I'd ask the person well how
do you distill and purify sulfuric acid
and they're like I don't I buy it like
why would you do that and then I'd be
like well how do you work with bromine
and they're like I I've never worked
with it before and in chemistry there's
a lot of like I call them like Boogeyman
chemicals because people will never work
with it but they just hear from a friend
of a friend that it's really scary yeah
so when I was in one of the labs they're
like they kept saying bromine if you if
you like go near it it does this and
this if you get it on your skin you lose
like it was like so hyped up but
everyone stop your new bro meme drop but
everyone's just so fearful that like I'm
fearful wanting to make it right but
nobody can help you because no one's
ever made it right right and almost
nobody's work like a lot of people
haven't worked like I want to enrich
uranium no reason why just wondering
does anyone know how to do it but like
the reason I'm saying this is that I
start to realize that most people don't
have like a they know a lot about one
topic they don't have a huge range of
chemistry yeah so it's like so what I
realized that my skill was not being
great at one thing it was being like a
mediocre a lot of stuff so like you're
not gonna make any breakthroughs but you
you have a very good understanding of
the general I guess like any
breakthrough because there were some
things like for example like when I was
looking on making like I say like Aero
gel superconductors there's people
probably out there who know how to do it
properly but the info is not publicly
available oh so you made it so it's like
I have to come up with a method and it's
like for for example one thing I did was
ferrofluid there's no recipe on the
internet like no there was not a single
recipe or tutorial on how to make it so
like I was super proud when I came up
with something that was literally the
only method on the internet do you ever
get like a lot of people like emailing
you Italian foods like everyone but I
also I made it it's one of the most
finicky things ever like I've tried to
make like eight times and it fails like
seven out of eight times and I don't
even know why but
it's like
your question was like am I really good
yeah I think I just built a confidence
of knowing like how to see something new
okay and then navigate it safely huh I
think it's also you have the confidence
to actually try it out physically right
whereas like as you were saying like a
lot of other chemists would just be like
be too scared to even try it yes and the
big problem since there'd be you can't
get there you have to find the people
who work with it specifically to get
help right because the average chemist
can't help you
um so even recently one thing I worked
with was hydrofluoric acid which is like
and the pro like a lot of these
chemicals that I would work with the
first time it's like legitimately you
don't see in the videos but it's like I
would be like shaky for certain things
because not only am I working with it I
have to film so it's sometimes like
weird awkward positions and I have to do
things quickly and but if I spill it on
me it's really bad right so it's like
not only am I working with the chemical
I like practice a little bit but you're
gonna get the shot but I'm not so
familiar that I'm super comfortable yeah
um and terrifying and with hydrofluoric
I'd ask some people who work with it and
they'd give you tips but it's like what
kind of tips don't well you know you
know what you're supposed to do don't
get it on you yeah right right like
where you have to there's all the
protocols of like wearing gloves you
wear like a face shield you wear but
it's still like nerve-wracking because
you've never worked with it before yeah
yeah and you kind of just have to yeah I
think even if you're in a lab like we
trained some people when I was there uh
with chemicals that we would say they're
dangerous you can't get it on you and
like this people would be like shaky
right we would have to be like that's
just part of it like you have to get
used to working with it wasn't too crazy
but it's like when you come from working
in Labs where it's like all like more or
less just like completely yeah but the
other one is like you just like don't
you don't want to breathe it in so you
have to be careful you're not going to
die if you get it on you like the stakes
weren't that high yeah it won't be a fun
time but it you obviously probably be
fine but it's like just because you've
never worked with it before you're like
really afraid of spilling it so it's
like and you're trying to like use like
a glass pipe head and it's like maybe
put it in a tube so you have to be
pretty accurate yeah and then when you
see yourself shaking that makes you more
scared because you're like now thinking
you're gonna spill it yeah so you have
to I find that that was a lot of
they're just building a confidence that
I'm like okay I've I've tried a lot of
stuff and do you ever worry that you
make it look too easy
so
it's actually a very good question
because that's what like not that fear
directly of like whether I think it
makes it too easy
but I feel like I make chemistry
look like
not it's not fun no no not like so I
won't say like fake yeah but it's kind
of like the movie version you cut it all
the [ __ ] up so there's no it's all clean
it's not it's it's none of that like I
people don't know when I plan my
procedures like I plan
Beaker swaps and how it's going to
appear in the camera so it's like I
won't fumble with things so like I will
if I if I have to take a beaker out
right away I will pour with my left hand
and then move with my right oh I'll plan
like the movements of my hands and so
it's like I if I have to like switch
beakers and stuff I also plan how I'm
gonna pour it how I'm gonna add stuff so
it looks very clean like actual
chemistry is insanely messy yeah like
when I'm off camera doing tests there's
just dirty beakers everywhere like
things sometimes I spill things and they
fall over but because I plan it so much
like let's say there's something here
yeah I plan the direction that I'm gonna
reach in and I even practice how I'm
gonna reach
so I don't spill anything so I don't
knock stuff like if I'm pouring
something I think it's going to be
difficult I I practice like three times
before yeah because in your videos you
make it look very natural yeah it's very
very smooth yeah very very like that's
why I say it looks kind of like it's
like the movie version because I've
practiced and some of them if I do screw
up I will redo the same thing like seven
times until it looks smooth right wow
yeah I always wondered if you maybe gave
some people false confidence in handling
some of these chemicals yeah
yeah with how easy you make it look
bringing up liabilities
it's like watching a stunt man jump off
a thing and then roll you're like oh
it's so easy I can do that and then you
do it and you [ __ ] it up it's like it's
like it's not it's not that it's not
your fault that you operate like
professional handling it it's like I
always just wondered if there's ever
that element to it where you're like oh
[ __ ] I gotta I gotta make sure everyone
knows this is [ __ ] dangerous
yeah I try to like slip it in like looks
I know I've watched I've watched like
the bromine video uh the ones that
you've done it with it and it looks
[ __ ] terrified it looks like an Elden
ring [ __ ] smog appearing it's
terrifying you do get used to working
with bromine though like that's the one
thing like after a while
I'm saying I remember the first time I
made it like I was so terrified yeah but
then now it's just like you because you
you know what it's capable of yeah like
I I don't think I tamed it I might have
spilled it on me before you know my uh
what like a splash on me and then you
why are you the thing is when you work
these are things you don't like and they
don't talk about like when you work with
it you have a bottle of salt like that's
not an antidote but it's like it's it
will neutralize it oh okay okay so it's
just like you when you work with it you
have to have that conservative if you
get it on you you just like I would just
ah and you spray and it disappears
instantly oh that's good so it's like
like
[Applause]
yeah you don't you don't want to risk it
obviously you don't want to burn or
anything oh of course I actually have a
scar here are you serious what's that
from from Acid oh my God but that wasn't
from filming my own videos
it's actually for filming for will oh my
God I was filming or I don't remember I
think I think I was filming yeah I don't
know if he was filming something was
happening and acid spilled on me but I
didn't want to ruin the shot
so I just like I let it go until the
shot was done you just holding the
camera
why was acid being right you were just
like a huge e through and through you
know like I I feel like there are a few
jobs anything for the shot yeah yeah I
feel that there are a few jobs that can
really and that video is never posted
like there are a few jobs that can cater
not only to your expertise but also your
mentality when it comes to danger and
all of the ideas that you want to do
aside from being a YouTuber I feel
getting the shot like I've I've burned
myself before and everything just to
make sure if the shot's nice then you'll
say that again well I like I I mean I
said I've gotten burns like okay okay
because like
um
just to make sure that I know how to
handle it like this looks sick
how can you know if how could you know
if fire is dangerous if you've never
burned yourself
I'm self-inflicted for no reason you
know the first video I ever saw of yours
was and this is before I ever started
like watching your stuff a lot I
remember just popped up my recommended
and I watched it and I was like what the
[ __ ] is this yeah it was one where you
bought like anal lube I knew you're
gonna say that because did that blow up
like back in the day because how old is
this video oh that was one of the first
earlier ones I remember I saw this
you're like I bought this brand new anal
lube never used and it was like it's
funny is I don't I don't think that was
a joke
but it sounded like you know yeah no
like let me think she protests too much
you know it was I remember
like I obviously I remember doing it
yeah but I what were you making of the
anal lube again I was getting the uh the
local anesthetic at it
so what was funny though is like at the
time what year was this this month that
must have been 2015 or something yeah
this is like I remember I watched this
when I was like
I was still in like [ __ ] like school
yeah I didn't know that you you were you
were aware of uh those videos I watched
that one never watched you again for
like five years because it was like I
just watched this one video around
you're like it's the interlude guy and
then I remember I watched I was recently
watching like holy [ __ ] this is the same
voice as the anal lube dude so I
explained the anal Loopsy so I in the
video I said like now I got this anal
lube like brand new sealed never been
open I'm like
it's too good so funny but what happened
was it was it was weird because like
watching that really in my head yeah
made me realize how different my content
is now because my videos back then yeah
I would just drag and drop the videos
into the editor right I'd pick up a mic
and I would just say stuff I don't even
think I ever really said the line twice
right I just narrated what I saw yeah
right and I sometimes didn't even
re-watch I I for the first like I would
say probably
three years of my channel I never
re-watched the video
I to this day do not even understand how
they're coherent because I would
literally just say stuff as I saw the
clips right right render upload and so
like but I remember with the andal loop
part it was I think it was an actual
concern of mine that people
comments the comments would be like oh I
bet this is his so I think I was
actually defending myself right it just
makes it look worse but
it was like not like a joke when I did
it right I know but it makes it sound
like you but like re-watching this it
was absurd to me I'm like why did I say
this not sarcastically like I was
genuinely defending myself
it's good it's good I'm sorry to bring
that up does everyone bring that up no
what's funny is that like that's one of
the ones that is brought up a lot and
even more recently people shared like a
screenshot it was another guy on YouTube
he was like complaining about YouTube
recommendations and he specifically
referenced he's like what have I done to
deserve this recommendation he's like no
offense to the Creator but seriously
YouTube and I was like okay and even
like I took a photo of it I was walking
through I don't know maybe it was
actually sort of a different video okay
because I was walking through like Best
Buy yeah and I saw on the random
computer that one of my videos was
recommended this was like in 2019 and I
was like super proud yeah I remember now
it was not the animal I thought it was
which one was it it was like making like
a
sedative or something right not as fun
not as fun no for a second in my head
for a second I thought it was the anal
lub one funny
recommended at Best Buy I just wonder
what would happen if one day like the
police raid your home and like they they
bring out all the evidence you have to
be on a watch list right yeah
yeah so we found a inner loop uh two
crates of firecrackers
if I'm a dictator you're on my list like
watch this guy like just keep an eye
like don't do anything weird just just
see what he's ordering on Amazon
I think that like I mean
your Amazon order list must be insane
yeah so the Amazon stuff is fine I mean
there was there was a Heyday on on eBay
that was like I kind of missed right
what's this heyday well we could just
say there was a period in time where you
couldn't get any of those chemicals so
like that's why I was trying to make all
that okay okay then there was this time
where everything was available on eBay
like stuff that was like
nobody should be selling yeah like what
um some of them were like literally just
straight up listed as like uh like I
don't exactly remember which chemicals
yeah but it's like I think it's I think
one of them's like
I forget no it's not ethanol I think
it's ethanolamine right or something one
of them's just made to make like used to
make mustard gas so it's like they're
not really
like you can't and eBay was like oh it's
buy one get one free like they're very
heavily controlled right right
um I think importing it is just like you
can't do it yeah you can actually weird
enough you can manufacture up to like a
kilo I think without a license but you
just can't export it or import it okay
so does that happen with a lot of
chemicals you can make your own but
there's surprising a lot about like um
like I give not to go off on a huge
tangible like uh when I was making
uranium glass I really want to be
careful
that's such a good sentence
no no glass okay okay so I got some
uranium okay
okay that has to put you on a list I
refuse to believe you can buy uranium
and not go on a list so listen so I got
some uranium yeah okay well from where
if you're undisclosed
um no you can buy it like I mean Tech
you can buy in the US you can buy
uranium
and they'll just ship it to you I
actually don't remember where I got from
like I remember what you got you're
right here
I'm like you're not like you know you
remember when you got uranium from you
know how YouTubers have packages
we should get fan packages you're like
oh another fan box of uranium [ __ ] no
crap that could have been where it came
from do fans send you chemicals no okay
I don't really get anything I have a P.O
box but I always forget to tell people
that even exists right oh it's been
three years
it's just anal lube
I was very concerned like for for a lot
of my videos I find that I get hyped
about it and then like right when the
video is done or about to be done I
start to get concerned about the legal
implications
um so like the uranium glass one yeah
yeah I thought I thought it was like
it's cool you make uranium glass but
then when it was done I'm like
is it legal to work what's the
difference between uranium gloss and
regular gloss
it just glows under like a black light
it just glows because there's a Squall
in the dog does it have like uranium in
the dark yeah yeah but like a very small
amount because uranium gloves yeah so
it's like some forms of uranium
nothing to do with the radiation oh
really so this is the point like I
called the government and I was like I
had to call them it's on speed dial one
no I took actually there's a lot of work
to find the right number yeah right and
I called them and was like is it legal
at the time I was like hypothetic
I wanted to work with uranium
like what's the legal implications and I
was like honestly appalled with what
they told me yeah the guy said
almost all of the laws are related to if
you're using radioactive material yeah
for its radioactive properties but the
glow in the dark it's not glow in the
dark like fluorescent property of
uranium glass is a property of like the
uranium not the radioactive part so
there's
there's nothing we actually they used to
make dials right uranium so that would
be controlled you can't do that oh
really you can't that's radium which is
even worse it's a million times more
radioactive oh yeah the good thing in
watches right yeah yeah and uh
um World War II planes right there for
the finite the paint is like yeah you
don't want to but so if you get that
because the radiation is directly
related to why it glows like you'll get
slapped with with all these regulations
yeah but because the uranium has nothing
to do with the UV under like under a
black light glowing huh he goes there's
technically no law because no one would
no one would be how the who is get it
buying you ain't even doing this right
because no one would do it he goes
because the other one is like for it's
for like nuclear power and all this
stuff he's like these are the they have
laws for Waste Management and all this
stuff yeah yeah and he's like but for
like hobbyists making glass he's like
there's so I asked him like what do I do
with the waste that I made I'm like I
have like papers that are contaminated
with uranium I have like other stuff and
he told me he goes honest sleeve I'm
going to tell you by the law
you can just throw it in the garbage
he goes he goes you can just he goes is
it less than a kilo I think and I'm like
well yeah it's like maybe 50 grams he
goes legally you you don't you can just
throw it out and I was like and he goes
but
we strongly prefer if you don't
I'm not gonna make you I'm gonna make
you say it no I I saved it I just saved
it because I have like a little and you
put it in like um I have a little like
cabinet for it but he's just like we
strongly prefer you down
that's very sketchy
yeah I'm sure he would probably have
been quite worried so I was going to ask
like either that or like you must have
some lawyer who is absolutely sick of
you who you're like hey we've never
talked like to a lawyer I feel like you
should have a lawyer out of any YouTuber
forget look do you have insurance
yeah okay good good okay good good good
your insurance bill maybe I need more
after you're like calling out my Geico
like so uranium poisoning right it was
really hard to get insurance yeah I can
imagine [ __ ] it out like what are you
insured against like I
are you like are you educational like
what is it it was really hard to like
register as a business I was gonna say
right like it must be hard but obviously
you have to do it because you can't be
doing this stuff for fun and Publishing
it and making money right I wish you
could I mean what's actually so going
back even further like when I was the
most sketchy period in time was when I
did everything at my parents house thank
you see chemicals were just stored in
the room it was like just it was pretty
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and they're gonna say there's one
time a bottle uh I've already gone too
far actually I made something called
um
benzyl chloride I think you've I've
heard about this in your videos it's
like a vague it used to be used as a
tear gas I think it was used in one of
the world wars I don't remember or they
didn't actually make it was it's just
like a tear gas and just irritates your
eyes and the bottle corroded and leaked
into the room with all the chemicals but
that kept that room is nobody goes in it
except my dad goes in there to play
guitar and for like for like we didn't
dad why are you crying no we didn't the
big thing about it is it feels like very
very mild onions right it's like there
were like for like we couldn't figure
out what it was if we kept searching you
don't breathing-wise you don't notice
anything yeah but it would be after
you're in the room for like maybe an
hour
you just start to get like irritated but
the thing is that it would last for like
hours yeah so like my dad and I for like
a week or two would go to bed I remember
just like tears pouring out of my eyes
and we just didn't know what it was oh
my God who are these ninjas chopping
onions bro but that was that was one of
the big times I'm like I have to just
like this is
right now you have you have your own do
you have your own Labs right yeah like
everything is like up to code that's
crazy that's good yes
I also don't store any chemicals that
like could potentially leak and cause
anything yeah honestly I don't like
keeping those was that like a process
then getting your own place and getting
it all sorted kind of why I mentioned
this when I first started my parents
house I emailed the government and was
like how do I get like a permit to I
wanted to order chemicals and their
answer was kind of like it doesn't give
you anything like getting getting
certified as a lab is just bad right
because they're like what it allows you
to do
is basically have people work there like
it's like it's like you get a bunch of
other like abilities
that make sense in certain businesses
but if you're just doing hobby chemistry
there's no point they said they kind of
what's the difference between you being
like a painter and you buy a bunch of
people you want to make your own paints
like what's that different than what I'm
doing mixing solvents doing a bunch I'm
just saying like I get it I get it for
it
reasons I think it's very hard to like
make laws against right so there's
actually I remember I remember talking
to a chemical uh distributor and I
caught I mentioned a chemical license
and he freaked out at me a little bit he
didn't freak out he's kind of like what
are you talking about chemical license
I'm like because you know that doesn't
exist
and you can because the license you get
is with individual at least in Canada
individual chemical companies uh it's up
to their discretion to sell to you and
if it's not on a list of like prohibited
chemicals that like it's like a drug
yeah it's just up to their life it's
liability whether they want to sell it
to you or not so like there's no if I
buy some chemical that's kind of sketchy
like bromine you don't there's no permit
that allows you to own it okay do you
think there should be yeah
no because only the the chemical
companies have like a strong grip right
on who buys who can buy it right I mean
it's so heavily regulated yeah you sell
to like establish businesses all right I
I've been hyped up about bromine over
the past hour yeah what the [ __ ] is
bromine used for Nigel I gotta know now
I need to know so you want to know what
bromines used for besides having fun
yeah okay not much really uh no it's
it's I think it's cool
because
that was the most obvious I think it's
cool uranium is kind of hype it's kind
of in right now
um no so it's like it's similar to
chlorine so if you smell bromine it's
like a weird chlorine oh does it
disinfect things yeah okay so in some in
some like uh it's common in hot tubs no
yes right I've heard about this and even
some Pools use bromine I feel like it's
more common in spas for whatever you see
the products that like Spa products is
it cheaper than chlorine
I don't I know they kind of I think
they've phased it out it was abandoned
in Canada or Quebec because I think it's
bromine is toxic slightly okay like
compared to chlorine I think there's
like some toxicity issue uh compared to
chlorine so we're trying to phase it out
of pools yeah and I think they stop
selling them as Pool Products but it's
if you look at the periodic table which
I'm sure you're very familiar
no no I I'm saying this a joke because
there are people who in chem aren't
familiar and I barely look at it I have
an engineering degree but I don't do
anything I think it's like a meme that
like chemists look at the periodic table
all the time but it's kind of like
you I look up I look at it when I need
to and I don't remember half of it right
you don't have a poster of the periodic
table I do you have to it's right above
my my office
every lab has the periodic table in the
new office it's like you only look at it
when you need to either way it's like if
you look at it Roman's in the family of
um halogens so it's like chlorine
bromine iodine and fluorine okay yeah
right so it's like it's between I don't
know I'm in my head I'm like oh God this
is all bad it looks it looks the same
color as iodine right kind of no so as
you go down let's look fluorine's at the
top okay and then it's a gas go down one
and you get to uh
um
yeah so it's like oh no but you get to
chlorine which is a gas yeah then you
get to bromine which is a liquid and
then below that's iodine which is a
solid solid right and solid normal yes I
didn't know that yeah it's normally a
solid if I had I'm like oh God did I get
that order wrong so um so it's very
similar but it just looks cool because
it's like a black scary looking liquid
it does look like an Alden ring boss
it's about to spawn out of it in all of
your videos but it's using kind of like
just specific chemistry reactions right
um it's used in organic synthesis but
it's like not that
okay you're basically giving bromine a
use of giving it all the heights yeah
purpose you're bringing the bromine hype
I've used it before to do a chemical
reaction it's just not I think just it
looks cooler than yeah so use it on it's
visually very appealing yeah okay okay
because I just wanted to make it yeah
like this black scary liquid okay that's
fair enough
um
yeah oh no go for it another question I
have is you say chemicals are restricted
right I I okay maybe this is like a bad
question to ask or maybe this question
was like don't ask that question
what let's say there's a chemical that
is very prohibited but you can buy two
other scary chemicals that can make the
very scary band chemical what how does
that work are you like if you buy the
chemicals like you better not make this
with it well if you were if it's in the
US yeah like in the case for meth oh
they just
okay okay because meth is like the
probably one of the most well like the
one thing that people synthesize the
most like people also synthesize cocaine
and like all this other stuff it's just
that meth for whatever reason is like
the most well-known that people make it
yeah for whatever reason well I'm just
saying like it's the most
like if I were to say people make like
synthesized cocaine you're probably like
probably where's like it's kind of a
meme that people make math okay okay but
it's like what they did was it's kind of
for a long time it's like a race between
the sketchy camera I'll say sketchy
chemist and
um the government yeah so like At first
okay meth is illegal and guys like hey
well I got the ingredients for math
these aren't illegal so I'm just gonna
make it I can buy these and I can make
it right right then the government goes
okay those chemicals are illegal yeah
the guy's like well I have two chemicals
can that can make that chemical right so
they would just keep going down the
chain right and with meth it's gone so
far like it's like you're like sometimes
like I think it's like four things down
the line right and you get you get to
the point where it's just like such an
obscure chemical that you can only buy
it from a chemical company right because
it's just like a petrochem like made in
Industry right there's almost no way for
you to just make it yeah
um and then you want to buy it from a
chemical company they will go like what
are you using it for and they'll write
your name down and they'll only let you
buy a certain amount right but there are
still ways around it of course like
there's still I mean I'm saying like the
illegal like the the that's so funny the
people who are six
people who are synthesizing math
right yeah yeah to do it I mean
obviously the fact that you know people
are still making it they well sometimes
they just go they just it doesn't even
matter that like four chemicals down
it's band yeah they just illegally
import either the meth itself or they
just illegally import the one ingredient
lower one ingredient right and a lot of
it's from China I think China would not
to call the map
uh I think because they don't they would
just I I forget a friend who was
involved like he knew a lot about it he
didn't make it
that's such a funny sentence but you
know I know a lot about turkey okay okay
you just say that like it was a big
thing on like Chinese websites that they
would make
I don't know what they would advertise
it as stuff like stuff that's very close
to drugs right but as something else and
then you could buy that but I I honestly
don't know too much is it like is it
like the herb Grinders and you know like
that kind of advertising well see like
it's not a bong it's a water pipe yeah
yeah well like one thing that they would
sell like designer drugs for a while
so like straight up like almost
basically math they would sell it for
like research purposes and you could
just buy it in the US because it wasn't
a scheduled drug I don't know all the
details about this but they would also
sell like the chemicals and stuff you
could find like sources and like I said
my sketchy days on eBay I didn't buy
anything like that but there was a guy
who's like
tell me what you want I can get you
anything
that's not what you want to hear that's
not what you want the stuff that was
just listed on eBay shouldn't have been
listed there all right what was like the
craziest stuff you saw listed on eBay
it was um hydrazine what's hydrazine
it's used for like rockets and stuff but
it's like if you see what they use like
if you look up hydrazine it just comes
out wrong people handling it are in like
full body suits because it's a very not
pleasant thing to deal with anything
about the FedEx guy's kicking it around
I love a certain percentage it's like
really bad but so I think it's a I don't
know what if it's a gas or a liquid it's
pretty bad so you usually sell it as
like a 60 or something High
concentration in water yeah but the cow
just ship it in like an unmarked brown
box in like plastic bottles I never
bought it I actually regret I was like
I wish I did I wish I did because it's
hard like even though I can buy I can
order chemicals yeah I think what I
wanted to order hydrazine I had to go
through all these was it legal in Canada
to have the chemicals again there's no
laws
order it yeah well if you try to order
it from a chemical company they will ask
you like a lot of questions yeah ah like
what are you doing like specifically
like what are you using this for
um and so some things can be a big pain
to get have you ever had someone reject
you for chemicals where you've been like
hey I'm just making this one I've had
one company which they wouldn't they
would not let us have an account and
they wouldn't tell us why and we think
it's because they don't want their
products to be shown on camera but
you're not showing the product
endorsement I guess
it's not like you're saying here we have
bro uh bromium given by the the kind
people at chemical Corp they also might
not have liked it because I I kind of
like um let's show the antelope video
maybe yeah no I I I just every time I
use their product in the past I'd always
like say negatively and unfortunately
you would name the company yeah yeah
I said it because they're just the big
thing is these chemical companies are
really expensive oh sorry so it's like
to give you an idea there's one chemical
I want to buy like let's say 100 grams
if you buy from them it's like could be
like 200 I bought it on eBay for eight
dollars but they guarantee certain
Purity the difference is the eBay one I
had to purify myself
[Music]
um but it's like they're worth buying
from they're just very expensive for a
lot of things so that's that's what I
would complain about okay okay you say
like I had to purify myself like this is
just like a thing that you just do yeah
I mean like it's just like a simple
thing to do right because chemistry it's
just like I I think yeah it's like super
normal this is like the weirdest Rabbit
Hole I think I've ever I think chemists
scarier scientists like they're the ones
that I am just scared of the most oh no
I believe it's just conversation they're
just terrifying like I don't because we
just don't know what the [ __ ] you guys
are doing yeah what chemistry because
because the thing is like you look at
like the The Sciences and like you know
with engineer you know you can like the
a normal person can kind of follow along
with what an engineer is doing what he's
building because you know it's a lot of
the times it's it serves a function you
know you can also like feel it and see
what's going on exactly yeah that's the
problem I don't understand what's
happening again yeah yeah when you name
a [ __ ] chemical I'm just like uh does
that burn your face off or does that
give you like a light tickle like I have
no idea what the [ __ ] you're handling
that's like the biggest challenge if I'm
going into chem is it's like a game
except there's so much knowledge you
need to just get started
um like organic I think that's like how
organic chemistry is right it's like
just it's just a game with the most
except you need to read what is it and
it's permanent it's like you have to
learn you have to study for like three
years just to like play it start playing
what is organic chemistry as opposed to
normal chemistry so chemistry in general
is split up I guess into like three
major sections okay I could be wrong on
this but like my understanding is like
uh inorganic chem organic chem and then
physical whole cam okay so physical cam
is basically physics it's like the
intermediary between the chemistry right
because chemistry is a lot of physics is
a lot of chemistry yeah in a way well so
it's like the moment you start doing
stuff that requires I say physics so
it's like you can have some chemical
reactions
um require lasers so it's like it would
be all of like the people who are doing
laser stuff are usually the Fizz
chemists okay and they do a lot of um
actually I don't even know too much
about Fizz cam just I know that when
you're in organic chem which is what I
did yeah
um you always just say that this Cam's
boring and you feel bad for everyone
who's in it but I don't actually really
know
could you take a few well you take a few
Fizz chem classes it's all
thermodynamics uh you're doing a lot of
like like just calculations
um so what's the difference between
chemistry and organic chemistry though
so the organic and inorganic is
basically the difference between carbon
and non-carbon
oh and they're easily there is like a
crossover right but like organic just
ref and chemistry is just carbon based
so anything any chemistry involving like
the braking or modification or building
of carbon-carbon bonds or carbon
um
related to carbon is organic and is that
a lot of things in most things it's a
lot but the thing is that like any
chemistry you do with like nitrogen or
Metals so like iron copper so if you
take acid and pour it on copper that's
inorganic chem because there's no carbon
involved so like people generally
they'll Branch off
into the tube usually like people go
like I do inorganic inorganic chemistry
primarily or organic but there is a
crossover where people can do like
um a lot of catalysts are inorganic so
people like that's the lab that I was in
when I was doing my grad studies it was
kind of even weirder too because it was
like it's inorganic things inorganic
molecules so it's like a very big
crossover and then you catalyze organic
reactions but a lot of catalysts like
copper metal just copper metal can you
you can use to catalyze
[Music]
there is a bit of crossover between the
two oh God you give me like PTSD from
chemistry level but a lot of people who
spec out an organic chem will then know
not like do you get very much into
organic chem yeah and then you know you
know enough about inorganic it's like
your thing requires it but it's a very
different chemistry of course right and
then the people who know all about the
inorganic stuff will then be much
fuzzier about the or the carbon based
stuff so how did you get into like
chemistry at school like presumably
after the blowtorch I mean I at this
point it just feels like natural right
yeah you're obviously very knowledgeable
now but like how did it go from being a
crazy kid in the backyard to getting a
formal education yeah because you said
you wanted to go to the veterinary right
yeah so like how did it go from
Veterinary to just doing the chem stuff
so I'll I'll look I'll pick up where we
left off sure after I was making flash
powder I quit I I never made it I don't
know why I think it coincided at some
point with like a fear of firecrackers
right yeah and I was like I just want to
blow my fingers off so I just and since
then I don't like explosives like I just
kind of stopped yeah but
I got I really want to make thermite
[Music]
okay which you know thermite is it's the
[ __ ] that bones like ridiculously yeah
right yeah yeah and so it's like
aluminum and iron oxide yeah so
everything that's dangerous so I really
got into like making the rust okay to
make it and then trying to make aluminum
powder I kind of like I think it kind of
worked once I've actually never set off
or might huh I just kind of had no
success in that realm okay okay but
I guess I call I've always like just had
like a lot of the I always say the
projects I really liked just happened to
be chemistry right right right so when
you went to school and they were trying
to teach you all this boring [ __ ] were
you like oh that's easy I did that like
when I was two no so like around that
time I was doing chemistry in high
school and I got like 65 I thought I was
gonna fail the class and I remember
being really scared because I won't get
into the science program right in my
with Stage happens which basically like
it's in just before University right
yeah we have something called uh sixth
forms
for two years right yeah two yeah yeah
so I just was like I didn't really care
about the theory yeah so I didn't really
study I just didn't really understand or
care right
um well you're not blowing anything up
right you're not not dissolving anything
why would you care I'm not in any
immediate danger
I don't know I just I don't remember
having any like strong thoughts about it
yeah I just kind of always but my dad
was has a background in science so
growing up was always like I'm a science
guy so I just should do well in this
like I didn't think too much yeah
um and then going into sejab I also I
didn't do well in chemistry it was
actually my worst science subject right
I kind of hated it um
I just didn't care for too much Theory I
guess but I got to do organic Camp right
and I don't know why it's like so I
described it as like a game it's very
much like once you know the rules
I liked in my head like picturing how
the molecules would move around and like
how to build things that's what I liked
about organic yeah and like solving the
problem to me was satisfying right that
makes sense yeah yeah so I just I just
liked the idea of organic chemistry and
I like the idea that you could like
have things and you could build other
things out of it with your knowledge
right I thought it was cool
um so I thought learning about different
reactions was just interesting yeah
right uh but up until then I still
hadn't done like any
real chemistry
um until University
um what constitutes is real I did I say
I did nothing okay
um I wasn't I really want to do like
filmmaking stuff like it was had nothing
to do with well now you combined me yeah
well that's exactly so it is related so
I got obsessed I think it was in like 20
12. I got obsessed with spicy food and I
really wanted to extract pure capsaicin
from peppers
because I was just like I wanted that
explains the interaction we had in L.A
we should see how we met you yeah so we
we had a little get-together at our
Airbnb and then and Nigel turns out and
uh whips out a vial of pure capsaicin
he's like hey you want to try some and
so he pulls out a needle and gets it out
what unsharpening what does that mean I
I have this great footage of Nigel
preparing it all like we're putting on
the gloves I could hear them yeah I I
remember just like having a drink
chilling outside just like having a nice
little chat I come in and [ __ ]
Nigel's no no I just got a needle now
and putting [ __ ] on a violence it sounds
like some Horrors
look like a horror I was like yo you
what what kind of [ __ ] drugs are we
shooting up for this party what like I
know we're in LA but come on guys come
on your cap station which I don't know
if I would I don't know if it would be
less insane if you guys were just doing
drugs because at least it wouldn't make
sense he was wearing gloves as well yeah
so it just was like even more concerned
when I first this so this is like kind
of relevant ah whatever I was I'll just
go back
I was obsessed with spicy stuff yeah
yeah and I don't know why I went through
a phase I'm like if it's not spicy I
don't want to eat it fair enough and I
wanted to taste pure capsaicin I don't
know why so what I started just like
trying to extract it but I was too poor
to afford gloves so I would do
everything without gloves oh my God I'd
be like pouring solvents and so like my
hands you could get these solvents but
you couldn't get a [ __ ] pair of
gloves acetone from like the hardware
store like gloves are cheaper than the
message they were like twenty dollars a
box or something at the time like 15 a
box I think I had I think I had negative
money in my bank account right the
solvents were like my dad's garage soft
okay okay
um
so I got I would get it all over my
hands all the time I would touch my face
so I got like that's why I told you I
got super used to just like
capsaicin oh my God
but again that was another like science
project that I didn't really care that
it was like it's kind of heavily
chemistry yeah
so I'm like reading all these forums on
how to like do extractions and like
chromatography and like all this stuff
I'm like I just want pure capsaicin all
right first time I didn't succeed I
think it was about 50 what I had okay
right okay did it taste it was spicy
that stuff you gave me
yeah and it was pretty spicy it wasn't
like it wasn't as crazy as I thought it
was going to be I because I gave you
guys like I
I didn't know how you guys handle it and
it's like if I gave you you could get an
amount that looks like nothing but it
like the next 30 minutes depending on
how you handle spice like you might
think it's gonna ruin your entire night
I handle spice pretty well and I'd say
it was it was it was definitely spicy
but it wasn't like
the amount that I gave people and I was
like if you're good with spice you'd be
fine yeah yeah the whole test is if Joey
ever does it which uh we're wearing up
in the hospital probably I mean I've
gotten better you have gotten better I
used to be like zero tolerance of spice
but like you know the this year I had a
ghost pepper for the first time I would
say that's worse on it it all's the dose
right yeah so it's just like I find
actual fresh peppers like really spicy
peppers are probably worse than what
you'd have with uh with capsaicin right
even though it's really concentrated
yeah it doesn't really spread around
your mouth right so like honestly like
the spicy Wing challenges are like worse
your all your lips are bad like it's so
and then you're hiccuping and like the
next day your stomach just hurts yeah
whereas like you don't get that if you
have like um capsaicin there's so little
it doesn't even irritate yourself
although you say that but I remember
specifically when you were giving a
little bit of the Pure Cafe corner you
were just like don't swallow it because
you're freaking me out because you're
like don't swallow just don't swallow I
give it to some people and it's like
they Panic oh yeah so I was trying to be
like I'm not going to give you a lot
like if you don't like it don't panic
just spit it out you're whipping this
out and giving it to people when back in
the day when I was like doing it at home
like when I extracted myself it was like
anyone who would
you're a manager
I haven't asked the important question
why did you have a vial of cap station
just yeah just in your bag and what else
do you have in your bag that you can
carry around
there's a reason because like for one of
the videos I was making a spicy compound
and so I brought it a very small amount
the last time I was in LA right yeah but
I just kind of like I didn't bring
enough I didn't like set it up properly
so it's kind of a disappointment so when
I came back I was like I'm gonna bring
spicy stuff again but it had been like
six months or seven months right I
didn't have the other stuff anymore the
stuff that I made right so then I I was
just like I'm just gonna bring how does
like TSA react to stuff like that when I
guess they didn't see it yeah
so they don't know can't hurt them right
yeah I guess so it's not illegal or
anything like you know it just I
remember
put it together as a kit to make it look
sketchy yeah
did you want it to look sketchy I
thought it was funny yeah yeah I mean it
also was the only way I could package it
yeah but it's even the little plastic
bag I had like I purposely I thought it
was funny yeah um definitely looked like
a mad scientist just like whipping this
thing out yeah uh completely off top of
the question is Breaking Bad done good
or bad for chemistry
has it helped it or has it made it more
annoying
um
I don't know I mean I feel like we're
witnessing the origin story of like
future water yeah that's what I'm
thinking about it is it like a meme
amongst chemists were you talking about
breaking bad or was it just like a it's
kind of a thing where you roll your eyes
yeah so it's kind of it's like
I think Breaking Bad was I don't
remember the show enough I think it was
accurate enough in a certain way but
it's like if you do chemistry there's a
lot of stuff that I like the show like I
thought the show was good and you've
accept everything that comes with TV
yeah but it's like when other people
kind of like
no I don't know how to describe
um
kind of like the the feeling right but I
guess maybe one thing would be because
like the math they made was blue yeah
and they'd be like Yo dude like could
you make super pure math and I was like
I mean in theory like any competent
chemist
Ry basic it's basic techniques like what
they did in the show were like very
basic techniques they're like averages
well no like straight up if you want to
know it's like the most basic technique
is recrystallization yeah which is like
if you know the solvent you literally
just dissolve it you heat it up dissolve
it and then let it cool down and the
crystals come out
and like for math not together
does Walter White look like an amateur
in the show then
uh no I mean they hiked it up to make
him look like you know really super
genius purifying a lot of these
chemicals is like very very basic
chemistry even like when you mentioned
before you're like oh you say
purification like it's normal yeah in my
lab we didn't trust even the chemicals
that were certified by the company right
because everything we did was like very
like
um not like it was very like sensitive
to water and air and stuff so we
re-purified everything and it's not
uncommon for labs to just purify
everything they get just to make sure
you just to make sure it's foam right
right so it's like all these techniques
are like very basic so it's like when
people ask me that I'd be like I mean
anyone who's done organic chem like it's
maybe probably gra even above ground
like like just undergrad yeah right they
could figure it out like it's not really
that complicated but I was gonna say
like they go could you make the meth
blue and I was like what so what you
want me to do is contaminate it
because meth is white like it's clear
like it's gonna be it's gonna be like
most pure organic compounds are just
colorless right yeah so to make it blue
you have to put food coloring in it or
something so you're like can you make it
pure like make it blue and I'm like
that's an impurity yeah so like it's
stuff like like it's not annoying but
like it's like this weird hype
about
um
it's like it's like this I don't know
how to like I don't know what the proper
term is for like people's view of
chemistry
yeah I really don't know how to describe
like the feeling yeah I feel like they
might have just like simplified it or
just stunned it down maybe I would say
that it's kind of like this is a maybe a
bad example but like when people think
of Like a Surgeon or a doctor yeah it's
like if you don't know anyone in the
medical field they're just kind of like
these these Gods who are who just have
Infinity known right right and people
kind of view that about chemistry yeah
it's weird to me about like certain
techniques where like I said I'm like
you take a cup of like at you just pour
acetone yeah you heat it up on a a plate
that gets hot you add stuff until it
stops dissolving and then you just wait
for it to cool down and then it comes
back out and you're like well it's more
pure now like it's not really
um
it's not like this crazy like space age
thing but they would say it to me as
though like you could you could do like
this purification and I'm like I they're
not it's not very I'm not annoyed by it
but it's just like it's this like you're
talking out like you're talking [ __ ]
yeah you're saying things that are wrong
I don't really know how to describe it
it's like it's it's not a bad thing
necessarily yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying like on one hand it's like
they're really interested in chemistry
but they're they're into it in a way
that doesn't really represent chemistry
I have a question it's not a bad thing I
want to know but I didn't want to Google
it because I I feel like Google how to
make meth all that like I don't care I
was like I didn't want to see my history
you don't break your bed right this is a
scene and it stuck with me because I'm
like is that true it's like you've been
waiting for this moment I need you to
know and I'm sure the people who have
watched the VPN yeah
are sponsored if we if we actually have
an extra VPN sponsor this would be great
so there's a scene of Breaking Bad and
I've always wanted is this just [ __ ]
you know when they they want to dissolve
the body yeah and they have to get a
specific type of hydrofloric yeah right
and they have to get a specific plastic
is that true I just yeah so it's that
that's one thing I think I watched The
MythBusters thing where they tried to
dissolve it they dissolved a pig I
believe and it did work yeah but just
not like it did in the bag yeah and it
didn't go through the bathtub exactly
exactly so you could do it in the
bathtub normally so here's the thing
hydrofluoric
I mentioned the acid before right
because I said it was one of the
chemicals I worked with recently that's
scary yeah you don't work with it
commonly like fluorine and hydrofluoric
acid are just not common could you get
enough theoretically to fill a bathtub
as well like is this it's hard like even
you could like a lot of these acids are
are industrial acids right because like
just like in [ __ ] Breaking Bad he
just gets it you're like oh worldwide
knows how to get a vat of acid it's
definitely like it it's one of those
things like even like cyanide as an
average person you're like I can't like
where do you even get cyanide if you go
to like some places that do like for
example a gold plated cyanide is used in
like gold refining and stuff they will
just have Drums of cyanide like just
like it's insane like dozens of like
just like thousands of pounds of cyanide
on pallets and stuff because it's
industry
and obviously you need it so obviously
when you're buying it it's not sketch at
all yeah that's why even in Breaking Bad
it's kind of realistic where he's like I
know where to get methylamine and he
like steals it from a company yeah
because it's like they do use it for
legitimate stuff and it's like you can
they will have tanks of hydrofluoric
acid that you could steal but it's like
ordering if I would be like I need a
thousand or a hundred liters of
hydrofluoric acid I don't I think you
can go online the companies the most
they cap out is like four or eight yeah
and it's like it's really I bought a 500
mL bottle because it's lab they all give
you like the high Purity lab right so if
you want the industrial crap if you're
especially if you're gonna dissolve a
body yeah yeah but it's like if you get
the lab grade stuff it's like a dollar a
milliliter like it's really expensive I
was gonna say like is there like the
perfect crime in your head of how you
would do it because you obviously know
all these techniques right so like have
you planned like like I'm not obviously
you're not gonna kill someone
I don't know if I did it fully answer
your question that you had I think maybe
yes there's like is it true that there's
like Plastics so I should say that
that's what I should say just as the uh
whatever the last thing hydrofluoric
yeah dissolves glass
whoa so that's like what I I in a video
so I want to do it like show right it's
used for glass etching in Industry so
it's like very common which is why I'm
saying it's like an industrial acid so
people do it if like sometimes I
remember exactly like if you need to
etch glass to like Bond things to it or
to do like surface treatments they will
do a hydrofluoric acid rinse first so
it's really not uncommon but you it's
sold in plastic bottles so it's like
when it's a pain because when you do any
chemistry with it you can't use
glassware
how do you distill it you actually have
to use I think stainless steel like you
can't oh so you have to boil it right
yeah but it's called oil and plastic no
it won't it won't boil it's maybe some
high temperature but you wouldn't I
wouldn't do it in plastic but it would
just melt hydrofluoric acid though
think reacts with steel and iron to make
like iron fluoride but it blocks the red
I think it blocks the rest of the metal
from reacting like it forms like a
passivation it could be wrong but it's
like that's not in my desk if it's in
the bathtub even if it like etches away
some of the surface yeah I think if it's
like a if it's like a steel bathtub or
certain Metals okay like it will get
stuck okay so all right I think I think
I could be wrong
I
have a body don't ask why how do I get
rid of it okay what I would do is I
would hang up
the police
put you on mute
um so you're asking how do you dispose
of a body what's okay in the movies in
the movies because I assume in the
movies it's all [ __ ] right yeah so
my my perception I've talked about this
before I think that like
just recently I think we're in Japan
talking about it right I think anything
like your problem is you have a body
right that is the problem that's the
problem that we're trying to say the
solution is to not have a body yeah
right okay I think the more steps you do
in between is just you're leaving more
evidence
because I was gonna say like if you buy
the acid you buy acid right if you do
this thing you do this thing this whole
movie is just [ __ ] right well I'm
just saying like if you go okay the best
way to dispose of a body I'm gonna chop
it up yeah you just get blood everywhere
it's like I just think that like I'm
just saying that like I feel like you
just are leaving a trail of evidence
behind whereas I watched like
what's like the dumbest thing well I
used to edit I I still at it but I used
to edit like and just watch
um a show a e I think there's no and ABC
2020. yeah which is just like murder
cases and it was kind of interesting
because they showed you like they
followed like from beginning to end like
the court case and everything
and what I kind of figured out from
watching it was the guys who got away
with the murder
put the least effort in getting away
with the murder oh just Chuck it in the
river or something well the guys who
were who are like trying to like stage
like a story and they bought fake plane
tickets and like did like all this stuff
they just got caught yeah because it was
so incriminating whereas like the people
who didn't get caught a didn't have
necessarily like a direct tie to the
person I was gonna say like I feel like
the moment you have a tie to someone
it's already problematic yeah but like
some of the ones that the people did
they just took the body drove to the
middle of nowhere and just buried the
body and like that it was just like
all right I've got it I'm going to feel
it it was like it wasn't like this crazy
movie scheme yeah uh there was even one
that was kind of crazy the guy just took
the body he lived near the desert just
drove in nowhere Nevada and buried the
body yeah right and they knew that I
think he had killed a couple people and
they literally spent like with hundreds
of people searching for like I think
weeks never found the body and [ __ ]
Nevada yeah and what happened though was
they made it they cut a deal with them
because I forget exactly why this is
real right yeah yeah they cut a deal
with them because the families wanted to
know where the bodies were and they knew
he killed one person but they could not
get him on the murder of the other two
and they cut a deal with him because
there's no body they're like as far as
you know there's no crime and the deal
they cut with with him was if you tell
us where the bodies are to give the
family like closure we will not try you
for those murders and the family agreed
to it
where the body was and they found it but
it was impossible to find and I was like
the guy didn't have this crazy scheme he
just insane like trade offer I've ever
heard no they said that the investigator
was like it was one of the worst like
offers he ever had to make right yeah
but he was like at this point we were
never yeah and guess what we would never
he was never gonna get charged anyway
anyway yeah
um so at least the family gets closure
yeah but it's like if you have like a
place where there's like somewhere where
you can dump a body like bury it they're
like you just can't and it was it was
like not like just wasn't a big scheme
right right I don't even know it's just
yeah just like there wasn't this crazy
like oh dissolve it yeah this whole [ __ ]
is just about a bunch of [ __ ] but it's
just like why dissolve an acid then you
have a bathtub full of yeah I was gonna
say like like what do they always I
guess you could drain it down but then
all your pipes just just because like
when the plumber comes in and be like
hey uh
like uh it's gonna sound crazy but uh
what drain cleaner were you using yeah
like I mean I'm sure there's some method
that you know some coming off camera
somewhere no I'm seeing something some
criminal organization has perfected it
yeah but as far as I know I just feel
like everything you do you're dumb it's
not necessarily dumb I feel like you're
just just every step and thing you take
in between it's just more you could get
caught on I don't know what compelled me
don't have a body yeah I was just I was
I just wanted to ask that question
because I was like I was like I wonder
if he's ever thought about it yeah okay
and that was how to get rid of the body
with now we're in everyone that is going
to be an interesting clip I've actually
never really put any real thought into
it I thought you're about to say like
I just imagined if you were watching a
movie and you saw it and you're like oh
this is not this is such a better way to
do it you gotta you know I think what's
kind of weird is like
I don't know I've just I've literally
never thought about it yeah correct like
I thought I think like you've passed
you're allowed back in the country I
think like the the surface level I have
might have just like
you see that yeah crazy asset and you're
like well that would be great like if
maybe that like if you vaporize a person
with that like maybe there would be no
evidence Left Behind yeah but I'd never
really like there's no thought after
like you know a fleeting four seconds
yeah well it's like because it sounds
like to do the stuff you do you have to
like search up some pretty dodgy [ __ ]
what's what's like the weirdest thing
you've had to search up on Google that's
to do what you do and a lot of people
search history I want to look through it
yours is definitely the top of the list
I don't know I just got you like I said
I just search anything I don't really
think too much of it and you've never
ever been contacted by like a government
agency about anything well once oh it
was so it was really mundane okay okay
I'd love to hear anyway so what's weird
about Canada too is like I find they
just don't really they're not super
strict on a lot of stuff in the US I
probably would not be able to have the
same YouTube channel yeah yeah really
they just raid you for math like every
week are you serious yeah like I was on
a forum for a while before I started or
before I really got like did YouTube a
lot there's a science Forum or chemistry
it's called science Madness yeah and
it's like a lot of people just talk
about how they just would knock on your
door they'll just swab everything to see
if there's you're making that and but
I've never been contacted like
foreign
interesting how like YouTube has this
kind of weird ecosystem where stuff that
would channels that could only exist in
a certain country yeah yeah and not in
others right yeah like how there's a
bunch of gun content on from America
it's like no other country could ever
make this type of content exactly and
Canada is actually one of the few places
in the world that you could have like a
proper and there is the uh explosions in
fire uh the Australian guy oh yeah
what do they contact you about the
government it was just I literally it's
because I it's actually meth related but
it was not not methrelated in the sense
that they thought I was making that yeah
I just bought a really big funnel and
like so
in in chemistry that's great that's good
chemistry there's like there's two
levels of I guess like glassware and
just just scale okay so when you do
research people call like it's not
really a term that people use I guess
but this one
I don't really know if there's a proper
term but you'd be like quantities that
you do research with okay so usually sub
a gram right right so like maybe up to
five grams no usually it's like a gram
and Below okay a lot of research
chemistry is like milligrams yeah okay
oh so if you're buying anything more
than aggressive no it's just expensive
okay and a lot of the chemicals are
expensive you're just you do you're
wasting money you're just wasting money
and resources and you get the same
answer right but the moment you think
you have a good reaction a lot of times
you have to scale it up so you do like
preparation so it's like preparative cap
which is a different thing because like
I'm working in beakers on like let's say
like 500 mils yeah 250 they're pretty
small yeah but sometimes people are like
my chemical I've used very dilute
conditions I don't make too much to make
let's say 10 grams I need to work with
like three liters yeah so you're no
longer in the one liter Beaker you're
kind of with like giant big things so
that's fine with beakers because they're
kind of just cups yeah but you start
getting the like the big funnels which
are very abnormal for like research chem
right so it's like most people who do
that are they're preparing chemicals
they're not researching they're like
synthesizing chemicals on a larger scale
for people to research with no oh like a
lot of people in research are trying to
just like as far as I know like prove
that their reaction could be scaled up
okay that makes sense and some people do
it on the preparative scale like uh
the chemical is like really expensive
but the two things that make that
chemical are cheap so they'll buy a lot
of that some of them will stockpile like
a kilo of what they need and that lasts
them like their entire research project
okay okay that makes sense but they
don't do it often and like often in like
some of the labs like the lab I worked
in you'd have like one of those funnels
or maybe maybe two and this one is
abnormal and sketchy it's just the fact
you're only using it to make large
amounts of chemicals and usually yeah
that's it you're just making a larger
scale not usually yeah okay so so you
buy it right and it's like yeah and it's
like a little bit specialized because
it's like a full glass like vacuum
funnel
the thing is that it's kind of like it's
used for math well in meth there's kind
of a I think it's a 22 liter round
bottom flask it's in Breaking I've heard
this thing
I swear I've heard that why what do you
mean are you gonna get the 22 liter
round bottom flash yeah so it's like
it's a it's literally a thing that in
the U.S in certain places you're just
not allowed buying it right or so if you
buy it it's like very suspicious since
breaking bad or since before breaking
it's just what are you doing with it
like why do you have to make so much of
it because it's just such a big you're
preparing so much of a chemical yeah
that like unless you work for like a
large-scale industrial synthesis company
why doesn't average why do you own this
right okay so so the moment you get past
a certain size and you're like a private
citizen yeah what in God's name could
they be doing with it but uranium fine
right just fine I'm okay honestly they
probably I don't remember where like I
said I don't remember exactly where the
uranium came from but probably if it's
like fully labeled and was shipped over
the border right
I did order from the U.S uranium it was
fully labeled and actually they didn't
say anything right so okay so you order
the the funnel online yeah it was a call
or what what is it it was a funnel like
it was like and you on like a website
eBay a lot of glassware from China okay
so you get on eBay right and is it
before it arrives right after it arrives
when does it when do they call you I had
it I think for like
I want to say like a week when they call
you up yeah I got a call from a guy and
the RCMP is the federal police in Canada
okay but the guy is just like yeah you
know I got a notice from like the
Customs uh that you bought a funnel you
bought something and um I need to follow
up on it I promise I'm not making messes
I would be shitty but I could tell that
he was in a cruiser like in a car right
he was calling me driving yeah yeah so
and he said he goes yeah I get
follow-ups I have to like just follow up
on these things I need to know what
you're using it for and at first he
sounded very suspicious because like
he's like you bought it online I'm like
yeah and you can you know you get that
like from law enforcement you get that
oh yeah yeah
they're trying to like pin you something
yeah yeah like he's suspicious and then
I went oh well like you know I run a
YouTube channel and he's like YouTube
this is like 20 I wanna say 2017. yeah I
was like YouTube what do you do on that
channel and I was like oh I do chemistry
and if you he's like he's something you
I can look up and I'm like yeah yeah
everything I do is like publicly
available he goes oh okay uh yeah okay
anyway I just he immediately sounded
like you want to be off the phone you
got your channel you just see like
notepad open up today I'm going to teach
you how to make math
no he immediately sounded like he just
didn't want to be in the conversation
anymore and he was wrapping up and I
even said oh uh do you think it's a good
like should you want my channel name
music oh yeah that's probably a good
idea
just the moment that I even gave like a
reason that was half reasonable he was
like okay cool because I think most
people could literally not explain why
they have it yeah right right I would
hopefully order it I'll probably
professionals
it's pretty very easy for them to be
like yeah I'm just doing this I said
he's I think he's like I said they're in
my videos he goes if I looked up I think
he's like if you if someone went and
watched your videos could they see this
final I'm like yeah yeah it's gonna be
in one of these yeah you have my word
officer no he just suddenly was like
okay this sounds too reasonable yeah
whereas if I wasn't doing any of that
yeah like if I didn't I feel like having
a YouTube channel where everything's so
public is what has
this is what I'm using this is how much
uranium in my head actually the evidence
is there it's literally all the evidence
yeah so you'll just see exactly and some
people but you could be making meth
behind the scenes and it's like to me
that's like no it's the weirdest like
conspiracy thing where
I don't know if you'd follow this but
I've seen some conspiracy stuff where
it's like so dumb and everyone's like
well there's hiding in plain sight and
I'm like why would I build an entire
YouTube channel
I could just make math and not publicly
tell everyone I'm a chemist
but I I can't okay to be fair though be
pretty [ __ ] smart no but the amount
of work to make the videos
I just want to see the new Breaking Bad
awkward water white just like stars like
a YouTube channel or the irony would be
that you start that was the cover yeah
but then the YouTube channel started
making more than that yeah I'd like to
think so you just phased out
I mean there is a world where I could
compete the irony is that like you're
yeah your YouTube is more lucrative than
math you're right water white is small
brain for [ __ ] buying a car wash yes
exactly follow the money yeah officer I
just I needed to spend 10 million
dollars on 10 liters of bromine I mean
what can I say yes just buy really
expensive chemicals that you don't have
to be using it's a perfect cover-up I do
buy a bunch of extensive chemicals that
I don't get that tax bill down I wanted
to know about
um this is completely unrelated to
anything uh this is a great Channel
called Nile green what do you think
about this channel wait what is it I
thought that the era of now green is
over is it really we don't talk about it
anymore is it really no one is what is
an algorithm you've seen Nile green
I mean I know if they're all red yeah so
I assume it's something to do so there
was a a guy another Australian man these
guys are very good yeah he's probably my
mate yeah yeah uh he at the time I
didn't I think I knew you I knew he's
Australian because you go to the about
page it said Australia but
he
would put my voice into uh like an AI
bot
he literally had like a perfect voice
Channel yeah that would basically like
learn your kind of cadence and how you
sound and then you could type out what
you want the person to say
it's kind of like I would say it's
similar to like not a bad deep fake but
I'd say like an okay deep fake in terms
of like voice faces right where it's
like oh it's close enough that if you're
if you're not paying attention you might
be tricked but if you like actually pay
attention yeah you're like okay that's
clearly you can see like artifacting so
when I first heard it like this guy
would make these videos right and I
heard it and like for the first like
yeah like 30 seconds I'm like I never
said this and like then you hear it and
go okay this is clear like it's a robot
it's like a parody channel right yeah
they would do like these parodies which
were actually good like I would say very
very good like it's not like those low
level parodies where they're like oh he
does chemistry again like I know
Breaking Bad let's combine the two I'll
just do like some like chemist industry
meme stuff yeah he had he would like
reference things that were like very
obscure and I watched it I'm like this
guy has to have a chem background right
like he has to know chemistry I guess he
would be even making like references to
like chemist chemical processes and I'm
just like again they're not like super
in-depth but I'm like this guy knows
chemistry
yeah like he knows that you can't
Channel and he's he didn't just learn it
from watching the channel like he knows
you've got to watch this it's stuff's
crazy now you're describing so it's like
even the filming like he would do things
where like
this guy knows how to edit like it's
it's an insane amount of work like he
would do things where I'm like I don't
even know how he edited that was that
like flattering or was it like what the
[ __ ] is happening I watch I loved it
when I first watched it I was like I
thought it was so funny the problem was
that like after he had made like five or
six videos
it was when people started being
confused they thought it was me I was
like I was like okay this is like kind
of thought it was like a second Channel
or something yeah because he even copied
the aesthetic and the gloves and like
the lab coat sometimes like he would it
would look really similar to the point
where people thought it was me right and
I was like okay if this guy has bad
intentions yeah he could actually like
like someone kind of commented on it he
goes if this guy just like started doing
like really racist stuff really like you
know kind of like just offend holy
offensive or even illegal stuff yeah
it's like it people might think I'm
doing it yeah and then I get in trouble
right right that's that's crazy that
we've gotten to the point now where
someone can like in person your voice
yeah to the point where they can
genuinely like affect your livelihood
yeah because the the machine is so good
at imitating it I need it it is crazy I
got to see this no I just play a little
I'll play it oh no I'll play a little
audio clip
I got bored feeding wieners to my acid
so today I felt like exploding some
sulfuric acid here is my stick of
dynamite this is made with love like
it's not perfect but it's shocking how
good it is but even even the aesthetic
yeah yeah just to prove this is sulfuric
acid here is the pH let me reiterate
this is the pH so he did make the things
like he did make piranha there so when I
watched it I'm like it wasn't just like
an effect like he has concentrated
sulfuric acid and hydrogen peroxide and
he's making legitimately like a very
dangerous concoction yeah so I'm like
this guy knows chemicals so that's the
thing too is like he wasn't just deep
faking it he was good at video editing
putting the videos together Kim worth
some kind of movie where someone saw you
replacing it yeah yeah like I think that
I've actually been movie plots that are
legit that right yeah so you reach out
to him so he
since he's Australian and there's very
few Australian uh like YouTube creators
yeah I guess too
into chemistry so he knew the other uh I
said the Australian guy explosions and
fire
um
I don't know who reached out to who but
Tom who runs explosions of fire told me
he's like hey dude like I've spoken to
him yeah yeah so then now there was like
um a connection a connection right right
uh so then we ended up just like he
wanted to do another video or he wanted
to talk to me so I'm like okay I'll talk
to him I ended up saying like if you
want to make another video that's fine
like I don't want to just come in here I
think it's funny I don't want to come in
here and just be like shut down yeah
your time is done and I'm like but if
you keep making it like I'll probably
have to do that because you are like is
potentially a liability yeah and I'm
like I don't think you have any bad
intentions but it could go it could go
the wrong way and I'm like I don't think
it's unreasonable that people are
thinking that I run this Channel and
there's like some issues it could be
like I could see if someone had anyone
maybe wanted one or two videos and
passing and they find this Channel and
it's branded a little too similarly they
got a lot of views oh no they they have
a [ __ ] ton of these so it's like it was
enough people that I was like it's gonna
cause problems but it was very
reasonable he's like oh I agree so he's
like that's good yeah that's good but he
also said he goes like and it makes
sense from a guy who put that much
effort and made such like high quality
stuff yeah as a parody like the amount
of work that went in was insane yeah he
goes I like filmmaking I like writing he
goes I I don't want to be just a guy who
parodies one person yeah and he was
that's like he was what I'm just in
forever just making parodies of you he
goes that sounds horrible to me yeah so
he's like I want to do YouTube I want to
figure out like the type of content I
want to make so he goes I was gonna
phase it out anyway okay oh so it was
kind of you know yeah so he's like do
you mind if I make like one or two more
videos and I was like look if you have
really good ideas for both yeah you can
make two I'm like but if you only have
like one hype video that you know of now
and he's like yeah I don't really know
what I do for the other one I'm like
then probably just you know yeah so he
did and then he I even said after that
too should probably change like the
channel from like 9 green to something
else and he did like I didn't he just
ended up like a month or two later he
ended up just like changing oh that's
good that's oh he was like he clearly
was not a malicious person we had him on
our podcast too oh yeah okay okay I
wonder like if let's say somebody used
your voice I'm like could you copyright
claim that yeah that's a very
interesting question well I've never
copied where I claimed my own image like
you know like if somebody because it's
you know you have image rights yeah but
I don't know if there's any laws of
voice rights uh you know vocal rights or
it's it's I think it's like one of those
areas that you get into that you're just
gonna if you I would say if you have
enough money you can sue anybody yeah of
course but if you don't want to bleed
yourself dry trying to like it's like
what I I assume with every dollar I have
right right and now you stop making
these videos but I have no money and I
didn't I just wanted to like let's say
you know someone clearly imitating my
voice and it's good enough where people
genuinely think it's me and I copyright
claim them and then they counterclaim I
wonder if what YouTube would be like huh
hmm I don't think you can so copyright
is for like a a published work
so I don't like your voice the tone of
your voice is not copyrightable
I don't think but I think that like
if people stealing your likeness this is
your likeness right that's not illegal
they would have to seal it and you have
to prove damages
well it's it I think this is a whole new
[ __ ] territory because yeah this is
never it yeah it's never really become a
big enough to deal with the next few
years is like impersonators who would
just buy their voice yeah yeah exactly
but it was like unless they're damaging
you like if they're just yeah I get that
makes sense if they're selling your
likeness and they're like going on the
street like I'm so and so and everyone
who walks by is a kid this is not the
guy yeah he's an impersonator but it's
like if you actually start like
pretending and then making videos of
yourself and making fake videos trying
to convince the public that this person
is doing horrible things like then you
can be sued but that's a crime like
you're you're defaming them and yeah
yeah like potentially identity like it's
identity theft yeah but it's like just
copying the voice I mean my first
content was impersonation mainly so yeah
I mean
you have a charge fear I was charged for
my crap no I I I'm good friends with the
poor sector actually what did you do I
was anime and I used to copy a voice of
one of the characters and just make
videos about that and then yeah so you
pretended you were them or you they
people no I never said I was them yeah I
I didn't go around being like hey it's
me I was like I'm pretending to be this
character and for the first few weeks
people were very confused because
because I was still small and they were
like oh the guy they made a side Channel
yeah yeah I I didn't brand it as like
I'm them or anything it was just like
I'm impersonated the voice and did
stupid stuff that maybe could be
considered damages who knows because
I've actually thought about this because
I was just thinking how much audio
content is there of my voice oh people
can for sure yeah yeah it's just a lot
of hours of trash taste that we put on
oh God yeah you see make a [ __ ] deep
fake and like I've literally seen like
some meme videos because we talk a lot
on trash days yeah and I I there's like
I can hear a voice line that's clearly
me and I recognize that it's me I have
no recollection of ever saying that in
my life
that's a very weird feeling too yeah
like just thinking that like not
remembering
yeah yeah that's true
yeah so it's it's it's kind of scary and
weird whenever whenever that happens and
yeah I think that's how I felt when I
watched the first the Deep page that
must have been so creepy no but I was
just like I didn't say this yeah right I
remember saying I remember this video do
you have a like a [ __ ] split
personality yeah if you start like
questioning your sanity like okay
I don't remember putting the dynamite in
the acid yeah it's like I did he spliced
it's confusion for like a little while
it's like that seems like something I
would do but I just have no recollection
of actually experience what's the next
steps for now red then what's what's the
goal or is it just make more videos you
know you don't upload a lot
it's always like you know a push and
pull between method right now the meth
is like right right the best popping off
dude yeah once the market goes like you
know a little bit down like that he's
got the cover done so it's like depends
on what the the CPM yeah that's actually
why I only post videos every few months
is because you know meth production what
is the reason why your video just takes
a lot like what's the main like what's
is it just everything okay so I assume
it's just like a lot of testing right
yeah it's honestly putting the video
together oh really is like the last
video to put to the last video was the
hardest it took me I think I I like to
say like two and a half months of
full-time work where I say like there's
no weekends like you're just working
yeah as much as you can every day for
two more months that's the film and then
to edit was like a month and a half a
bit over a month and you editing all
your videos yeah because I promise you
have so many videos you have all this
like random data you've collected and I
have to put it all together but they
have to do the research to like present
it and I have to figure out the ways to
present it so are you just doing a
thesis every time you do a video I think
she is doing it some of them take just
forever right um but like why they take
a really long time to post it depends on
the project like some of you some things
I've filmed in like a day and I edited
in like four days this was like two
years ago it depends on what you're that
was like the peak when I could do a
video in a week
um but I realized I like the ones that
take a while yeah and now I'm trying to
figure out like how to balance
I like I really like the filming part
but the editing is you got to get
yourself an editor bro but it's not the
actual Act of editing right it's like
decide like the biggest problem for me
is like how do I present all the
information
so like for example I'll have let's say
I don't know unfair fluid or one of the
things I've done
I will literally have like let's say 30
different things that I'm like I have to
mention this or it doesn't make sense
and it's like where do I mention it
because the thing I hate in I don't hate
it in science videos but I don't like
taking pauses to explain things it's
like everything I explain has to be when
it's relevant right that makes sense you
don't like like massive information
dumps right no so it's like if I'm gonna
mention this point it's only at a point
that it's relevant right so I have to
then take time to write and put all
these points in at certain parts right
it's like what parts do I include what
don't I include and then I have to like
watch my own videos and then be like I
did this and then let's say color
changes why there's no documentation
yeah so I have to go and look at it and
it's like I could hire somebody there's
no notes they just have raw video right
sometimes it's like a terabyte and a
half of just raw video yeah and they
don't even know what happens in the clip
but I know that out of the four
40-minute clip that twice in it I added
something right and the color doesn't
even change but I remember so it's like
I know where to find those clips and
look for certain things yeah and I I
mean so you you upload these videos it
takes you so long right and does is
YouTube how does YouTube view it is it
like do they demonetize it often or is
it age restricted because I wonder like
what how they what's the CPM on like
those kinds of content like is it what I
wanted to watch gaps in time or what is
it like what does it like categorize it
as yeah education educational education
I think it's it's that the long videos
I've been doing are definitely worth it
yeah because like in between posting
videos the AdSense doesn't really change
right so it's like when I posted it
spikes and then it goes like after like
two weeks it goes down but then it just
doesn't change yeah right and you have
infinite re-watchability because I watch
it like full time because I have no
[ __ ] clue what happened that's the
figure yeah that is why I keep getting
better nine million times it's like it's
just that the scientists re-watching it
10 times to figure out how to make a
fair well actually I think when we look
at the videos the average video the
average person who's watched the video
has seen it twice wow I mean people
people do apparently come back at a
confusion I think sometimes I don't have
to because there's so much presented to
you uh to you like at once yeah and as
someone who has zero knowledge of
chemistry I have to cut out like yeah
it's very calm do you do you get a lot
of people telling you that your voice is
just relaxing and then you just play
your videos and they don't even know
what's going on yeah I've done that a
few times because I'm just like I need
something in the background so I just
play you because it's like it's constant
it's like you don't change inflection
that's part of like
it's not the that's what makes the
voiceover hard yeah because like I try
to make it the most unintrusive ever it
is it's very much there's no like you
you don't like uh you're the way you're
talking is no the speed doesn't change
the volume doesn't change you've like
you're very good at it that's
that's honestly like props to you
because that's not easy like a lot of
people do very rookie mistakes when
they're recording and they the first
thing the first word they'll say often
is the loudest
so I learned how to not do that and like
at one point I tried to get like uh
compressors and everything to try but I
don't I just don't use any of that
anymore but even though like when you're
recording you can tell when a compressor
is compensating like you can hear I
don't like artifacts so yeah I will I
don't like you yeah I don't use any of
like the plugins but I yeah I learned
and it's like I never really looked it
up I just I just would hear the audio
and hate certain things that's funny and
then try to find out like the one was
like the lip smacking
so it's like all the mouth noises I just
couldn't stand I use plugins to get rid
of them oh I do so here's the thing okay
I still do because you can't stop that
you can't no no no there's no training
on Earth I remember watching some videos
and they're like when you speak lift
your lip off your teeth yeah like get
used to just not touching your lips to
your teeth when you speak do I do that
so I I've never done [ __ ] no I'm super
self-conscious about this [ __ ] but I'm
not saying like fully but like I've
consciously like tried to not and I
noticed it made it so that I I went from
like if you if you don't listen to my
early video you hear a lot more mouth
noises well this it's mainly zoo with
how much water you're drinking and the
patient you're drinking it so you want
to like drink a lot of water you want to
sip congratulations you're recording if
you drink too much it will sound really
[ __ ] Slappy yeah if you're too little
your lips will be like bone [ __ ]
broad you still need you definitely
still need to do the plug-in to remove
it oh yeah because it's natural like
everyone has it yeah but it's one of
those things that when you're listening
to someone naturally you just don't hear
it but I don't know it's like the mic
seems to pick it up even more yeah yeah
and yeah and there's another another
thing you can do if you are having the
problem of your YouTuber while you're
talking and you start because you know
you do a redo but you start the sentence
halfway so how do you make it sound like
you've done the sentence right so you
say something before it so you go like
okay now this is what I'm gonna do so
then the first now isn't as loud yes
because normally if you go the okay I'll
do another one right now and then you
Trail in so like exactly and like I find
that what do I do is you say the end of
the couple words from the last sentence
that helps a lot yeah but what I would
find is starting with T's and other
stuff yeah even when you Trail in
they're pretty
it's hard bad let's get used to it I've
never thought this deeply at all about
myself because you just be listening and
you'll you'll be listening to a sentence
I just randomly halfway through sentence
YouTubers will have this like audio
Spike yeah and it's like oh it's clearly
a cut yeah and it's like or even just
it's just slight but it's like ah it's
like it's I don't like it so it's like
when I I do all the I like audio work I
don't know why I like doing all the
audio work and when I take out all the
lip smacks it'll take out like 3 000 of
them and I'm like all these these people
don't have to listen to 3 000 it's like
with with YouTubers that do a bunch of
cuts right it does kind of lend it to
our lend well to the cut but every time
they cut they're restarting so they
start loud again yeah because they
didn't mean to but every cut is them
restarting and they're loud because you
start loud just because the way the way
that how speaking works is that you
don't have volume control very well on
the very first thing you said yeah
because you're just pushing air out so
it's quiet I think you got to get the
vocal cords yeah yeah it's quite like
explosive more explosive I don't want to
get you forget
you know but that's how it is so yeah
tip that's how you go top tip I think
I'm lucky that just my narrations has
always been like high energy yeah yeah
it lends well to high energy people but
if you're trying to sound
like just calm and just trying to talk
and narrate naturally or if you're doing
slow narration or you're doing dramatic
narration it's very important that's
where the birth of the what's up guys
literally literally that's literally
where it starts wait actually like I
feel like that's where it started it's
like it's that style version of that
that style has evolved because people
would just start by saying like what's
up guys and then it would Trail off
immediately yeah right not intentionally
but that style is just loud compared to
everything else and the thing that like
even with voiceover the thing that got
me too is like depending on the time of
day that you do it okay you didn't know
about this tell me tell me tell me so
because because my videos are so long
yeah and they could be like the last
one's like an hour of VoiceOver
you can't do it all in one sitting okay
yeah I I can't you can't like my voice
gets too tired yeah and also if you have
to go back and let's say I go I notice a
problem and you have to do you have to
go and replace a clip how do you not
sound different okay yeah that's yeah
yeah I've had those problems yeah that
that's been very helpful I have the
secret what is the secret what is it the
secret is for at least for me uh
whenever if you do because as you as the
day goes on your voice changes yeah as
you have like more where the morning is
notably more yes and you get exactly and
you get like it does change so I would
always do my narration like
around the same time around the same
time like never earlier than a certain
time right because I've had I've just
it's been warmed up from talking yeah
yeah and just doing that made it like
way more consistent well I I noticed
it's the time of day but also it really
much depends on sometimes it's the
weather that yeah sometimes like when
it's a really humid day like recording
in the summer I sound totally different
than recording in the winter yeah
because the atmosphere is different yeah
it is different thank you like an issue
like for one video yeah yeah between
yeah you definitely can and even over
time like if you go back and hear your
other videos your voice does change oh
definitely definitely yeah we've got
action changes easily my accents change
your [ __ ] ton yeah I remember you
mentioning that yeah I don't know if I
think I've watched the video that you
were in with oh gosh
my old accent you're mentioning it yeah
oh yeah yeah oh yeah I used to have like
a completely different accent but I mean
your voice changes all the time it's
very normal my voice if you go back in
my videos my narrow I didn't narrate
like I just kind of like I kind of just
talked and then I got sinus surgery and
my voice did change like significantly
right in my a lot of people commented on
it huh do you prefer your voice now is
then
I think so yeah like it sounds because
my nasal cavity got opened up so there's
like more resonance in it well I think
having some of it's better well I think
having a distinct voice helps a lot with
YouTube oh definitely I feel like you
definitely have a very very distinct
voice you know when your videos pop up I
know I'm watching and now I read video
it's just like
I don't know if I developed a distinct
Voice or if I just
like your voice is on the same level as
my mind as like chills like levels of
distinct on YouTube like no like notable
voices on YouTube it's like Nile red but
what I've never I've never said like
what's unique about it I don't know it's
just like when you hear your voice
there's no mistaking it that it's you
talk it's it's your Cadence so
yeah that that it changed because of
doing voiceover like for the channel it
would irritate me when I would because I
can't slur words right no of course not
yeah so I would just enunciate like very
yeah you're very clear it's impossible
for me to say no no I was like I wish I
had that power man I would I just became
very aware of it yeah I think it just
made me so conscious of how I spoke yeah
yeah because you speak like that off
camera as well so it's like it's clearly
like yeah I'm sure there's like some
voice uh over like elements to it as
well but I think just naturally you've
grown the ability it's from doing
voiceover yeah yeah yeah yeah I remember
when I first met you I was like oh he
sounds exactly like he does his videos
now what I've got here
he sounds scripted yeah I just
unscripted in real life every
conversation is scripted and I think
it's cool that you have a voice for
people like wow yeah I don't and then
they're like do the thing yeah yeah I
just love it like why did you oh it's
good it's good it's because there's a
lot of YouTubers where it's like they
have the YouTuber voice and then they
have their real life voice and it's so
it's the same but it's also like the way
that they say certain phrases and the
way that they you know the Cadence of
some sentences is very much like a
performative manner yeah on YouTube
whereas like in real life it's not so
much like I would say that they're
I mean I think everyone has that like
myself included right
um
in my sense it's like there are certain
senses I can't say on script because I
don't think it's they I just don't think
they have a good sound to them right
right so like there are certain things I
wish I could say but I can't like well
I'll stuff my head I don't know but it's
like if I'm trying to like word
something right saying the word sentence
in a certain way just doesn't sound nice
and sometimes I try to come up with all
these different ways on how to like move
the sentence around use a different word
yeah and I can't come up with it so I
just can't say the sentence that makes
sense that's pretty normal though I
think for voiceover yeah like certain
things like it's very tough for me to do
voiceovers that other people give me the
uh script the script because like you
said like I sound very similar to the
voiceover and it's because I don't know
why since the beginning of doing YouTube
I always wanted to be I like as close to
real as possible yeah cool so because of
that like I don't
I don't know why I just try to be like
as it's like the performative side to an
extent and the natural one don't it's
not it's not like one of them is like up
here it's like they both kind of come
closer together in a way I just want
everything to be like as real and
genuine as possible and that was like
since it started like I would never like
I even before I did any endorsements I
was like I will never endorse like
anything in any way that I don't truly
like use or enjoy myself yeah and that
was even before like the prospect of
anything like that right that makes
sense yeah because I totally get you
about the whole script things and
sometimes things sounding wrong because
these are just gonna test but whenever
we have like an ad reads I can't do it
so much because it's not written within
my voice yeah so it just so it's so
unnatural for like my mouth to I guess
make those movements and it just takes a
while to like like warm up I guess I
feel I feel it's definitely a common
thing with a lot of YouTubers who write
their own scripts in their videos yeah
like I feel with like it's like me and
Connor for example who don't necessarily
script our stuff all the way where it's
like it's I think it's a little bit
easier because we're not used to the
rhythm of you know a certain way that we
say certain things that only we can
write yeah I think I agree but I think
that for me too like just maybe think of
something how
as I would write the script out because
it's I think that's probably why my
voice and like the way I spoke changed I
want to be as real as possible yeah so
it became very very aware of times I
repeated words yeah when I said um yeah
when I did a lot of these things so like
any time I would say the same word twice
I didn't like that and I became aware
even in like everyday speech yeah I will
not say the same word twice I will try I
I just was like I became a I don't know
why I just stopped doing it right right
so but I mean that's not necessarily a
bad house it's not bad vocabulary
no it's just like it sounds bad it's
only really occurring to me right now
like let's say this you want to call
this like a bottle yeah if I were to say
like oh like this bottle is really cool
I if I were to have to say the word
bottle twice in like really close
together I would probably just not say
it I'd say this I wouldn't say bottle
right because I just became so oh you
know you wouldn't replace it with like a
synonym like you wouldn't be like this
bottle is really cool I really like this
container that that too close is weird
yeah but it's like I became abundantly
aware when like in a script so I'm gonna
be like this bottle is really cool it's
a bottle yeah I bought this bottle the
other day because I like bottles yeah
like that started just hurting me so bad
so I would be like just an everyday
speech I would stop repeating words if
they were too close and sometimes I
always get a sentence that I couldn't
find a replacement and I just kind of
wouldn't mention it I think this or like
like I just give up or I won't mention
it that makes sense I mean but it makes
no sense because people aren't and it
got really bad in text messages because
sometimes I wouldn't
I couldn't find a way to not repeat the
word right so I would just not reply
I think that's OCD no that's what I said
I realized I'm like my life is not a
performance there was no repercussions
to it yeah was the script good what what
script yeah oh oh okay yeah sorry it
wasn't like there were no repercussions
it's just that I started noticing the
lip smacking and the repeated words so
much that when I heard other people do
it
especially with my brother I'd be like
what is this guy doing like that's like
it would feel like nails on a chalkboard
so that when I would do it I would
suddenly become like weirdly self-aware
and it would stop me okay okay that
makes sense but that's why I feel like
it changed the way I spoke and the way I
did a lot of stuff because I was like so
aware I became super aware of the way I
spoke this isn't making the murder of
Melrose this is the the back back story
I gotta I gotta loosen things up how
many there's so many text messages
you didn't even get to talk about why
you're in Japan or anime or anything I
mean like I I mean everything else you
told us so it goddamn interesting that
I'd give a [ __ ] about asking about it
honestly I hardly said I'm gonna I'm
hardly said a word this podcast I'm just
like I just want to hear so yeah I just
want to hear more about what the [ __ ]
the Antics you've got on here as long as
you just have some guests who just have
such [ __ ] weird stories and lives
because you obviously like especially
when when you're the type of YouTuber
that you are that through your YouTube
videos we don't really get to see your
personality yeah yeah so I I find it I
find there's just so much more questions
to ask yeah that's why I find it fun
coming on like in doing so because I
just I mean before the podcast that like
uh safety third yeah before safety third
I never talked about anything yeah if
you didn't know anything about me you
just sat in the corner well I meant like
I was very not like everything is
scripted right so you be very careful
what you say like they didn't know
anything about you yeah no again I would
never be like I'm just gonna make a
video talking about myself like why yeah
right I mean I was the same way I wear
before trash taste everyone only knew me
for my scripts yeah nothing about what
you did to your personality right yeah
like that right and it's like unless
you're gonna go out and make like proper
content it feels like a lot of work yeah
whereas like it feels like what you're
trying to get out is casual yeah but
you're now going down the same path of
just like making more scripted content
to try to show how you're like casual
side no exactly so until the podcast I
just kind of didn't really happen I can
see why now through this podcast you
never did a draw my life because it
would have just been [ __ ]
hey you already just like so when I was
nine I bought my first blue tour which
is like you got a wild the one thing I'd
say is because it's my friend I should
give him a shout out Greg I don't know
if he's gonna watch this he's in another
he's he's in Australia
he he was the guy did like all the
childhood stuff right projects with I
remember him coming to me
um I went to team elementary school as
him but then like not the same high
school or Stasia but then we reunited in
University yeah I remember him telling
me he's like yeah in this time like I
talked to a lot of people about my
childhood and he goes I would literally
be like oh you know when you were
younger and you'd like build bike ramps
and they're like
no yeah he's like you know like yo you
play with fireworks
and he's like you know like BB guns and
they're like
I like to play video games I like read
books I play video games he's like I
started to realize my childhood wasn't
normal yeah yeah because like I was I
was going to one one thing I wanted to
ask was did you have video games we
played a lot okay okay
basically uh like long story short we
did all of this because we how old are
you I'm uh 26. okay so I'm 30. yeah and
I feel like maybe you you got like more
into the digital age younger yeah
whereas I don't think God internet when
I was like 12. so that was like the
Tipping Point of
there was nothing else to do yeah
as a 32 year old I would like to say
just because we didn't have the internet
doesn't mean we started blowing up [ __ ]
yeah it's like I said the internet is
the only thing holding that anarchy
like every 30 year old is just like a
mad scientists like after that I did end
up getting like really into video games
and that's kind of like the period I
didn't do a lot of projects but I will
say I also did things like you know I I
sometimes just put little circuits
together you click a button a light bulb
turns on I just I did some simple things
okay okay all right before you
incriminate yourself further I'd like to
tell the audience or want to promote
yeah shout out
your YouTube channel links down below
check them out everyone go check out
Niall green
everyone's favorite YouTube channel
thank you so much thank you for having
me go check out the safety third podcast
as well if you want to hear more crazy
Antics because we've we only had two
hours but I feel like we've not even
come close to unpacking everything I
should have like I feel like I wanted to
ask you guys more stuff too I don't know
we talk enough about ourselves [ __ ] up I
genuinely don't know like too much well
come on your podcast and then and then
we can reverse the roles then yeah just
ask me about anime when I went on and I
was like oh [ __ ] I don't know but hey
look at all these patrons though amazing
thank you so much they definitely blow
up [ __ ] when they were little who who's
the craziest Patron pointed one on the
screen right now uh where would it be
yeah
there you go there you go you did it
nice yeah I think oh cool no sorry hey
if you like to support the show then go
up to our patreon patreon.com trashtaste
also follow us on Twitter send us a
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
that face listen to some Spotify and
again yeah go check out now stuff links
in the description thank you so much for
watching bye
[Applause]
[Music]